und leute dann du darfst sagen für den sub 1 wenigstens hat windows heute gecheckt und mein
sound geht noch das ist ja nicht immer so gegeben unter windows dass das von einem aufs andere mal
noch funktioniert aber gerade dabei sind ich starte mal kurz mein 8 linux beide way use ich
8 und mama package updates aus champ nein alter vor allem wer gehen wir nicht auf den sack jedes
mal und ich glaube ich habe schon 20 mal gedrückt skip skip sie juckt das dich macht den update
check aus ja das kann man auch machen pausierungs champ so hier erst mal alles abbrechen was hier
noch läuft sagt abbrechen abbrechen abbrechen abbrechen wobei das muss man nicht abbrechen
abbrechen abbrechen wobei das muss man nicht abbrechen wobei das muss man nicht abbrechen
abbrechen abäusch egal packman update update was will er alles Ruby wird geupdatet und Prometheus
und Prometheus wie das die armies immer dass die haben schon so ein paar komische sachen
klar ob hetal geuzel wo dieser beatle juice und solche dinger kona prounciation nicht dass ich
besser werden wir im umgedrehten fall der
Ob es irgendwelche Jetbrain-Updates gibt.
Weiß ich eigentlich Jetbrain oder Jetbrains?
Ich glaube, die heißen Jetbrains.
Die haben mehrere Gehirne.
Das ist quasi Multiple Fivehead.
Welche ist das?
Ist das die weiße Katze?
Wo es diese...
Ist das die weiße Katze, wo es halt dieses...
Diese komische...
Hin und her geswitcht, wo es auch jede Menge GIFs gab?
Ach nee, die.
Das kenne ich nicht.
ZG.
Nee, will ich nicht.
Warum soll ich Hindernisse laufen?
Hindernisse laufen machen.
Ich renne einfach normal schneller.
Nächste Woche mache ich bei diesem Lauf in Frankfurt mit.
Aber da werde ich nicht...
Also da werde ich nicht mitlaufen, um volle Pulle zu laufen.
Da laufe ich mit meinem Kollegen zusammen und der ist langsamer.
Deutlich langsamer.
Eigentlich wollte ich Heise mal aufmachen.
Um gerade zu gucken, ob ich irgendwas verpasst habe.
What the fuck, ey.
Ne, ne, Heise gehen wir nicht auf.
So, Updates.
Updates durch.
Reboot.
Moin.
So wie Ezio.
Oder...
Ich...
Das ist...
Das ist der letzte Protagonist, den ich kenne aus Assassin's Creed.
Ach nee, Moment.
Da gab es noch Dings.
Den aus dem Dreier kenne ich auch noch.
Connor kenne ich auch noch.
Danach hört es bei mir aber auf.
Danach habe ich das...
Den Black Flag-Typ, den kenne ich auch noch.
Das war irgendein...
War das Edward?
Glaube ich.
Und ansonsten...
Keine Ahnung mehr.
Danach habe ich das nicht mehr so viel gespielt.
Aber bei Assassin's Creed habe ich auch gelernt, dass wenn man ein krasser Parkour-Dude ist,
dass man einfach an Wänden hochklettern kann, wo nichts ist.
Und es geht trotzdem.
Wieso ist Raid kein so großes Ding beim privaten PC?
Ich meine, ich könnte doch einfach...
Sechs billige HDDs und hätte mit Raid 5 Parität eine extrem leise Schreib...
Ja, hättest du.
Hättest du.
Du hast aber auch die Komplexität und das...
Also bei sechs billigen HDDs und Raid 5, da würde ich mir tatsächlich...
Das kommt in Sphären, wo ich mir Gedanken machen würde, ob du nicht durch Raid mehr Ausfall in Kauf nimmst als ohne.
Weil Raid 5 scaled sehr schlecht mit der Anzahl der Festplatten.
Mit drei Festplatten und so ist Raid 5 noch okay.
Ich glaube bei...
Ich glaube bei sechs Platten wird es langsam schon schwierig.
Wenn du Raid 6 nehmen würdest, wäre wieder was anderes.
Ich glaube, das liegt einfach daran, weil die normalen 0815-Noobs keine Ahnung haben.
Beziehungsweise sich nicht mit sowas beschäftigen wollen.
Und es auch ein gewisser, wie soll man sagen, Verwaltungsaufwand ist.
Ja, du musst es erstmal einrichten.
Wenn eine Platte kaputt geht, musst du ein Rebuild machen.
Das überfordert ja die meisten Leute dann schon, die richtige Platte auszutauschen.
Find mal die richtige Platte, die kaputt gegangen ist und sowas.
Ich glaube, das ist einfach zu viel Maintenance-Aufwand für die meisten Leute.
Wo das möglich ist, siehst du bei irgendwelchen Einsteiger-Nassgeräten.
Wo du dann drei bis fünf Platten vornherein schiebst und eine LED anzeigt, welche kaputt ist.
Ja, das kriegen auch die Noobs hin.
Aber beim normalen PC ist das einfach, glaube ich, nicht einfach genug zu benutzen.
Aber ich gebe dir recht, dass das durchaus Sinn machen kann.
Wobei man sagen muss, Raid alleine bringt dir halt auch nichts.
Es ist besser, das sage ich auch immer, wenn es um solche Themen geht,
es ist besser, wenn man einfach regelmäßig auf einer externen USB-Festplatte ein Backup macht
von ein paar wichtigen Ordnern oder von seinem Home Directory oder von seiner ganzen Platte,
weil das ist asynchron.
Das schützt bei Datenverlust viel besser als Raid.
Bei Raid, Raid ist ja synchron.
Wenn du bei Raid aus Versehen die falsche Datei löscht, ist die auf beiden Platten weg.
Also Raid ist im Endeffekt nur für den Fall vorgesehen, dass es kaputt geht.
Also weitere Verfügbarkeit beim Ausfall von Hardware.
Dafür ist Raid da.
Und nicht, um dich direkt vor Datenverlust zu schützen.
Und dementsprechend glaube ich einfach, dass auch die Notwendigkeit gar nicht so da ist in privaten PCs.
Wenn man da regelmäßig ab und zu mal seine wichtigen Daten sichert, ist man eigentlich fein.
Aktuelle SSDs und Festplatten haben eine Rechnung.
Festplatten haben eine recht geringe Ausfallrate.
Und dementsprechend wird wahrscheinlich die meisten der normalen PC Nutzer auch bei einer Platte keine Probleme haben.
Und wenn sie kaputt ist, ist auch nicht wild.
Neue Platte kaufen, Windows neu installieren und Dateien aus dem Backup Restoren
ist wahrscheinlich die einfache Variante für die meisten Leute, als sich um irgendwelche Raid-Geschichten zu kümmern,
von denen man erstmal wissen muss, dass es sie gibt.
Sich dann in irgendwelche Settings-Menüs trauen und sowas.
Na doch.
SSDs können auch kaputt gehen.
RAID ist dafür notwendig, dass man Hardware-Fehler abfangen kann.
RAID ist eigentlich eine relativ schlechte Idee dafür.
Achso, du meinst jetzt sowas wie RAID 0, einfach, dass man einen größeren Speicher hat.
Ja gut, stimmt.
Das braucht man mittlerweile eigentlich so gut wie gar nicht mehr.
Früher hat man das ganz gerne mal gemacht.
RAID 0, auch genannt Kamikaze RAID.
Ja.
Und das braucht man heute tatsächlich so gut wie gar nicht mehr.
Also sprich.
Warum soll ich zwei SSDs zusammenfassen, wenn ich mir auch einfach eine 2 oder 4 TB SSD kaufen könnte?
Und bei mehr Knet-Festplatten noch weniger.
Bei mehr Knet-Festplatten kriegst du ja mittlerweile easy 14 TB.
Ich glaube bis zu was? 22 oder so?
Die ganzen sind ja ultra fett.
Oder, ich weiß nicht, was die beste Preis-Leistungs-Festplatte ist.
Ich würde mal aktuell so auf 10, 12 TB, 8 bis 12 TB oder so tippen.
Aus Bauchgefühl mäßig.
Was so die beste Preis-Leistung ist bei Festplatten.
Und bei beste Preis-Leistung wird wahrscheinlich immer noch 3, 4 TB sein.
Aber für nicht viel mehr bekommt man, also wenn man rein nach Gigabyte pro Größe geht, kriegt man pro Geld geht, würde ich mal tippen auf 3 bis 4 TB.
Immer noch.
Aber es steigt erst viel später an.
Wir können da mal kurz ein paar Guides alles gucken.
Das ist tatsächlich eine gute Frage.
By the way, mein Chrome hat mich heute gefragt, welche Default-Suche wollen sie haben?
Da habe ich halt nicht Google ausgewählt.
Oh, guck mal.
Guides halt sieht anders aus.
Lass uns doch mal kurz gucken.
Festplatten.
Nehmen wir mal hier die ganze Seite.
Nehmen wir mal hier die ganz, ganz normalen Harddisk KDD 3,5 Zoll.
Und jetzt sortieren wir mal das Ganze nach Preis pro Terabyte.
Jetzt bin ich mal gespannt.
Gucken, dass wir es auch richtig rumsortiert haben.
Ja, haben wir.
Okay, Preis pro Terabyte.
Günstig.
Okay, das ist aber irgendeine, das ist irgendein Gebate.
18 TB Cloud Scale Capacity.
Da ist garantiert, könnte ich wetten, irgendetwas dabei, was man nicht haben möchte, oder?
Weil es ist verdächtig, dass diese ganzen Toshiba riesengroß Dinger auf den ersten Plätzen
sind.
Also entweder ist da irgendwas dabei, was man nicht haben will, oder sie sind wirklich
preis-leistungsmäßig unschlagbar gut.
Okay, so 8 TB.
Ne, guck mal.
Also bestes Preis-Leistungsverhältnis kriegt man tatsächlich hier so sogar schon in dem
Dreh, was eigentlich ganz, ganz cool ist.
Guck mal, das ist richtig günstig geworden.
Günstig.
Kostet immer 52 €.
Geht eigentlich voll klar.
Braucht man.
Braucht man einfach nicht mehr.
Ich meine, warum soll ich ein RAID 0 machen, mit irgendwie, keine Ahnung, 4, 5, 8 TB Platten,
wenn ich mir einfach auch 16 TB kaufen kann?
Also ich finde, RAID macht nur Sinn, aktuell noch, wenn man sowas wie RAID 1 machen möchte,
so für zwei Platten, dass man eine, eine, einen Ausfall abkann.
RAID 5 finde ich auch schon wieder unsinnig, gerade in Desktop-PCs.
Und man darf nicht vergessen, dass RAID generell bei SSDs meistens gar keinen Ausfall hat.
Ja.
RAID 6 meistens gar keine gute Idee ist.
Selbst RAID 0 ist es keine gute Idee bei SSDs.
Weil, also, wenn man es aus Ausfallsicherheitsgründen macht, RAID 1 mit SSDs ist vollkommen okay.
Aber gerade diese Sache mit, ich will meine SSDs noch schneller machen und mache deswegen
zwei SSDs mit RAID 0, kann durchaus kontraproduktiv sein.
Also was man damit vielleicht hinkriegt, sind so die klassischen sequentiellen Übertragungen.
Die kriegt man schneller.
Man kann quasi große Dateien parallel von zwei SSDs lesen.
Aber das ist ja gar nicht das, was man hauptsächlich hat im täglichen Betrieb.
Zugriffszeiten werden durch RAID zumindest schon mal nett schneller.
Ich will nicht sagen, dass sie bedeutend langsamer werden, aber sie werden auf jeden Fall schon mal nicht schneller.
Zugriffszeiten auf SSDs eher langsamer.
Das heißt, SSDs profitieren gar nicht so sehr von RAID 0.
Deswegen sieht man das wahrscheinlich auch selten.
Früher war das...
Also vor der ganzen Weile war das ja voll angesagt, dass die Leute...
Damals hat man beispielsweise so 80 GB Platten noch genommen.
Da gab es ja damals diese 80 GB Raptor...
War das Western Digital?
Welcher Hersteller war das?
Ja, Western Digital.
Genau, Raptor, Velociraptor und sonst was.
1 TB.
Da hat man damals davon zwei Stück genommen.
80 GB im RAID 0.
Das habe ich auch gemacht damals.
Bei meinem...
Was war denn das?
Adlon XP Rechner.
Ich hatte damals Adlon XP 1900 Plus, so ein Ding.
Wann kam das Teil raus?
2000?
Da hatte ich Windows XP drauf auf jeden Fall.
2001 bis 2004.
Ja, so in dem Dreh.
In dem Dreh, da hatte ich auch so welche drin.
Und ich sage euch im Nachhinein...
Damals war ich einfach zu doof.
Ich sage euch, im Nachhinein war das wahrscheinlich eines der schlechtesten Entscheidungen,
die ich je getroffen habe,
beim Hardwarekauf von einem Desktop-PC.
Mein RAID 0 Setup mit diesen zwei 80 GB HDDs.
Weil das Ganze wurde selbstverständlich nicht mit irgendeinem RAID Controller oder so
zu einem RAID geformt,
sondern ich hatte zwei von diesen 80 GB Platten
mit einem Onboard Nvidia RAID.
Damals gab es Adlon XP.
Zeiten war glaube ich Enforce 2 recht angesagt.
Ja, Nvidias Luxuschipsatz Adlon XP.
Das war ein Enforce 2 mit Onboard RAID.
Und das Onboard RAID...
Also quasi so ein Onboard Software RAID war das.
Es wurde im Prinzip trotzdem alles auf die CPU offloaded.
Aber nicht, dass das problematisch gewesen wäre.
Das war so schlecht.
Das war so schlecht, dass,
wenn mein Rechner abgekackt ist,
also wegen irgendwas, was an Windows verkehrt ist,
wenn irgendwelche Sachen...
Rechner sind damals noch ein bisschen öfters gecrashed als heute.
Wobei es unter Windows XP schon wirklich viel viel viel viel viel stabiler war
als unter 98 und ME und sowas.
Zumindest, wenn mein Rechner gecrashed ist,
dann ist der nie richtig gecrashed,
sondern der blieb einfach hängen.
Der ist einfach gefreezed komplett.
Und wenn ich da nicht schnell genug den Reset-Knopf gedrückt habe,
ist mein RAID kaputt gegangen.
Ich weiß nicht, ob dieses Phänomen mal jemand hatte
mit so Onboard RAIDs aus dieser...
aus dieser Generation.
Ja, ich wusste, sobald ich gemerkt habe,
dass mein Rechner hing,
musste ich instant den Reset-Knopf hämmern,
weil ansonsten hat dieser RAID-Driver
irgendwelchen Mist gemacht.
Vielleicht, weil meine CPU nicht mehr richtig wollte,
whatever, ich weiß es nicht.
Und das hat dann angefangen,
random auf den Platten rumzuschreiben
und die Platten kaputt zu machen.
Jedes Mal, wenn mein Rechner hängen geblieben ist,
ich nicht schnell genug Reset gedrückt habe,
ist erstmal Checkdisk angelaufen,
muss meine Platten checken.
Das war eines der, also wirklich,
eines der schlechtesten Hardware-Entscheidungen,
die ich auf dem Desktop-PC je getroffen habe,
so dort RAID 0 zu machen,
mit diesen ollen, diesen Platten.
Ich meine, das war schnell für die damalige Zeit, ja.
Damals hatte eine 80 GB Platte,
was war denn da schnell?
100, 120 MB die Sekunde
und das zusammen in RAID 0
hatte so 250 MB die Sekunde.
Da hast du gedacht, boah, Alter,
Poggers ist das schnell.
Sequenziell zumindest.
Ja, und Zugriffszeiten mäßig,
wenn die Dateien gesplittet wurden,
auf zwei Platten,
das war schon alles ganz nice,
aber ich habe danach nie wieder RAID gemacht,
im Desktop-PC,
nach dieser Erfahrung,
vor allem kein Software-RAID mehr im Desktop-PC
und ich bin von damals so abgeschreckt,
dass ich nie wieder Software-RAID 0
mit irgendeinem Onboard-Chip gedönst machen würde,
obwohl das heute mit Sicherheit
besser funktioniert als damals.
Aber das war echt nichts.
Das war wirklich scheiße.
Das war wirklich Schrott.
Habe ich jetzt eigentlich Updates gemacht und rebooted?
Also das war wirklich richtig,
richtiger Müll.
DieserFisch, danke schon für den Sub.
BlackHD, Pog-Subscription, Leute.
DantoDev, alle am Start.
Wie der Fabian jetzt sagen würde.
Start.
Nö, ist es nicht.
Wenn du deine Steam-Games nur drauf legst,
das macht aber auch im umgekehrten Fall wenig Sinn.
Also kannst du durchaus machen,
wenn du alles verlieren kannst,
was drauf liegt,
mit einem Festplattenausfall.
Du darfst aber auch nicht vergessen,
dass du die Ausfallwahrscheinlichkeit
verdoppelst bei einem RAID 0.
Egal, wie unwahrscheinlich es ist.
Solange es nicht 0% ist,
verdoppelst du die Ausfallwahrscheinlichkeit,
weil es zwei Platten sind,
die kaputt gehen können.
Aber davon abgesehen,
es macht, finde ich, wenig Sinn.
Man kann auch ohne Probleme
einfach eine 2TB SSD kaufen,
statt zwei 1TB.
Oder aber, wenn man jetzt sagt,
okay, man möchte sich eine große SSD-Platte bauen
für Steam-Games.
Warum nicht?
Kann man machen,
aber man muss ja auch erstmal
die 2TB mit Games vollkriegen,
wenn man da nicht jetzt irgendwie 30 Games
parallel installiert hat.
Na gut, moderne Games sind groß, ja.
Ich weiß nicht, wie groß ist aktuell Warzone
oder Modern Warfare 3?
150 Gig? 300 Gig?
Das wird ja immer größer, da bist du.
Da ist es doch schon relativ schnell voll.
Da kannst du gerade mal
sechs, sieben solcher Games installieren,
das ist deine 2TB SSD voll.
Ich weiß gar nicht, wie groß das aktuell ist.
Ich habe es auch gar nicht gekauft,
Modern Warfare 3.
Habe ich auch nicht vor.
Übrigens, ich bin ein bisschen später heute Morgen.
Und warum?
Nicht, weil ich rennen gewesen bin.
War ich heute gar nicht.
Gehe ich heute Mittag vielleicht noch.
War gestern aber erst.
Sondern, weil kurz bevor ich umswitchen wollte
auf meinen Streaming-Account,
ich habe schon am Rechner gelassen,
kurz bevor ich umgeswitcht habe,
ich war eingeloggt auf meinem normalen Account,
wollte gerade umswitchen auf meinen Streaming-Account
und da klingelte doch mein Handy von der Arbeit.
Und ich habe eine Nachricht bekommen,
das kann ich euch jetzt nicht im Detail vorlesen,
aber vielleicht kann ich es euch
irgendwie ein bisschen anonymisiert vorlesen.
Problem on einem Server und zwar Description.
Jetzt könnt ihr mal eine,
eine,
eine Runde,
Runde kecken.
Es ist ein Linux Server.
So viel,
so viel kann ich dazu sagen.
Linux Server,
Description,
System D Service,
MSSQL,
Confailed.
Und da dachte ich mir so,
wer macht denn auch sowas?
MSSQL auf Linux.
Da muss man sich ja nicht wundern.
Ich kenne die Kiste nicht.
Sagen wir mal so,
ich wusste,
dass da am Wochenende was gemacht wird.
Service State,
Critical,
System D Service,
MSSQL,
Contest,
Failed.
Ja,
und jetzt dürft ihr dreimal raten,
wie ich das Problem gefixt habe.
Also ich habe mich eingeloggt,
remote auf der Arbeit heute Morgen,
kurz bevor ich den Stream angemacht habe.
Eigentlich wollte ich den Stream schon anmachen.
Ich habe eher mir heute Mittag damit gerechnet,
dass eine Meldung kommt,
aber okay.
Ratet mal,
was ich gemacht habe.
Korrekt.
Reboot.
Und dann geht es wieder.
Also ich habe nicht den Service,
ich habe nur den Service restarted,
nicht den Server rebooted.
Also eigentlich nur Restart,
nicht Reboot.
System D macht jetzt noch
SQL Connections.
Nee,
System D startet die Datenbank
und irgendwelche Services drumherum.
Das war die Monitoring Meldung.
Ich weiß nicht,
warum die so aussieht,
wie sie aussieht.
Letztendlich muss das Problem gewesen sein,
so wie ich mir das zusammen gereimt habe,
ist,
die Datenbank lief,
aber es gibt zusätzlich zur Datenbank
einen Datenbank-Check.
Und das ist auch irgendein Service,
der mit System D läuft.
Und heute Nacht gab es wohl Wartungsarbeiten,
heute Nacht,
darum fragt mich nicht 1 Uhr,
2 Uhr, 3 Uhr.
Und die Datenbank wurde kurz restarted,
aber dieser Service,
der die Datenbank checken soll,
hat das irgendwie nicht richtig kapiert
und ist gecrashed,
als die Datenbank weg war.
Sprich,
spricht auch für super stable Sachen,
ich weiß.
Und ich musste heute Morgen
quasi nicht die Datenbank neu starten,
sondern den Check-Service,
der die Datenbank checkt,
der war kaputt,
obwohl die Datenbank selbst funktioniert hat.
Den habe ich restarted
für 2 Kisten
und jetzt geht es wieder.
Zumindest sind die Monitoring Meldungen weg.
Ob es wirklich wieder geht?
Keine Ahnung.
Ich verlasse mich einfach auf unser Monitoring.
Wenn das sagt,
dass es wieder geht,
dann geht es.
Easy Money.
Ich muss mal gucken,
wie ich das am besten abrechne,
weil ich kann mich dunkel daran erinnern,
dass ein Sonntags-
beziehungsweise Feiertags-
Rufbereitschaftseinsatz
mal 3 abgerechnet werden kann.
Das heißt,
ich habe mich da eingeloggt,
weiß nicht,
8 Uhr 45 oder so,
bis bei,
was weiß ich,
9 Uhr 25
oder sowas in dem Dreh,
weiß nicht mehr genau,
weiß es nicht genau,
muss ich gucken.
Sagen wir mal,
das waren 40 Minuten.
40 Minuten mal 3,
ja gut,
das hätte ich auch gekonnt,
120.
Gibt es quasi knapp,
knapp,
also nicht knapp,
genau 2 Stunden,
2 Stunden
Zeitgutschrift für
40 Minuten geguckt.
Ist doch
eigentlich nicht schlecht, oder?
Kann man sich nicht beschweren.
Es kann auch sein,
dass es ausgezahlt wird,
aber ich glaube,
es gibt Zeitgutschrift,
wenn ich einsatz,
also ich krieg,
ich krieg bei,
ich krieg in der Rufbereitschaft,
wenn ich nur Bereitschaft habe,
kriege ich es ausgezahlt,
sobald ich Einsatz habe,
ist das Arbeitszeit
und ich kann das abrechnen.
Dann nehme ich lieber
plus 2,
2,
2 Stunden auf dem Konto
als irgendwie
ein paar Euro mehr.
Ja,
im Prinzip hast du recht,
auf die Idee
ist doch keiner gekommen bisher.
Auf die Idee
ist doch keiner gekommen.
Sollten wir vielleicht
nicht so laut sagen,
sonst machen das doch Leute.
Ich glaube,
das geht bei uns auch.
man kann sich aussuchen
bei Rufbereitschaftseinsätzen,
ob man das als Zeit haben möchte
oder als Auszahlung.
Ja,
ich habe 6 Tage
am Stück Rufbereitschaft.
Ich habe,
ich habe seit,
seit Donnerstag
Rufbereitschaft.
Donnerstag,
Freitag,
Samstag,
Sonntag,
ah,
nee,
vier,
äh,
warte mal,
Moment,
Wann war Feiertag?
Donnerstag war Feiertag.
Also,
habe ich so rum,
Mittwoch,
Donnerstag,
Freitag,
Samstag,
Sonntag
bis Montag morgen,
ja,
okay,
fünf Tage.
Fünf,
fünfeinhalb Tage,
so war es mal 5 Tage,
war es Wochenende bei uns
nur 2 mal
und freier Tag bei 4,
ja,
das ist,
das zählt bei uns
auch nicht als Wochenende.
Also,
Ich habe, ich habe, sag mal so, ich habe, wenn ich Hofbereitschaft habe, habe ich das über das Wochenende bis Montagmorgen.
Sollte dort Einsatz sein, dann wird es nicht mehr als Wochenende abgerechnet, aber ja, ist mir auch egal.
Ja, aber Wochenende ist, also Wochenende, Samstag, nicht Sonntag.
Sonntag ist, Sonntag und Feiertag ist meines Wissens nach mal drei, wie das abgerechnet wird.
Samstag nicht, nur Sonntag, Sonntags und Feiertage.
Auf der anderen Seite muss man auch, muss man auch sehen, deswegen machen das dort Leute auch freiwillig.
Es ist ja nicht Pflicht, ja, es steht bei keinem im Vertrag, dass du dazu verpflichtet bist, Hofbereitschaft zu machen.
Aber dadurch, dass das ganz gut bezahlt wird und auch wenn was ist, die Einsatzzeit ganz gut abgerechnet werden kann oder vergütet werden kann, macht es halt jeder, wenn es sein muss.
Das ist halt eine gute Taktik.
Wenn man die Leute nicht dazu zwingen muss mit irgendwas, sondern die Leute freiwillig das machen, weil es sich lohnt und dann haben beide Seiten was von.
Ja, die Systeme sind schneller wieder da und verursachen keine Millionen Schaden dadurch, dass sie mal zwei Tage nicht laufen.
Und die Leute haben auch was davon, wenn nix ist.
Und noch weiterer, noch besser, noch besser, die Leute haben sogar noch einen weiteren Anreiz, ihre Systeme möglichst stabil zu bauen.
Weil du kriegst ja im Endeffekt fürs reine Nichts machen bei der Bereitschaft.
Gar nicht so schlecht Geld.
Das heißt, du hast noch einen weiteren Anreiz, dass dein System möglichst stabil ist.
So, lass uns mal gucken, was auf Shithub so trendet.
Die Woche.
Ja, aber Chat, ihr hattet recht, also ich hab genau das gemacht, ja, um das mal aufzunehmen.
Ich hab restartet und dann ging's einfach wieder.
Eigentlich sad, dass Tapes die letzten Jahre nicht so gut skaliert haben.
Ich glaube, das liegt an der Technik selbst.
Vielleicht können die einfach nicht besser skalieren.
Ja.
Weil du für Tapes auch extra Hardware brauchst.
Ich hab letztens auf Reddit gelesen, irgendein Typ hat auf einer Ebay-Auktion einfach mal geboten, es gibt doch, wie heißt das bei Ebay?
Es gibt so ein Angebot, Vorschlagen oder sowas, so schlage einen Preis vor, irgendwie sowas, ich weiß gar nicht, wie das heißt, gibt's auf Ebay.
Und er hat irgendeine Auktion gefunden, hab ich auf Reddit gesehen, guck mal, wie ich das finde, wo war das denn?
Reddit, Oracle, Tape, Library.
Das war vor, keine Ahnung.
Vor einem Tag oder so.
Das hier, glaube ich, ja.
Der Typ hat quasi random Kauf auf Ebay gemacht und hat erst bei sich eine olle Sun, beziehungsweise später schon Oracle Tape Library rumstehen.
Ich hab absolut keine Ahnung, was der Typ damit haben will.
Ist das überhaupt eine Tape Library, nicht, dass ich jetzt Mist erzähle?
Ja, ja, ist eine Tape Library.
Jetzt hat er eine super fette Tape Library bei sich rumstehen, was wahrscheinlich laut ist.
Falsch.
Schwer as fuck ist, schwer as fuck ist, Strom as fuck verbraucht, aber haben.
Guckt euch das mal an.
Dafür kannst du fünf Kühlschränke anschließen wahrscheinlich.
Ah, hat ein bisschen Gebäude und so.
Wo man sich jetzt fragt ist, es ist sicherlich cool, sowas zu haben, ja.
Es ist bestimmt nice und so, sich das anzugucken, sich zu freuen.
Die Frage ist nur, warum, weshalb und was machst du jetzt damit, wenn du es hast?
Chat, was würdet ihr damit machen?
Wir haben eine Tape Library.
Also ich wüsste es nicht.
Ich hätte wirklich absolut keine Ahnung, was ich mit einer Tape Library machen soll.
Weil, weil, anschließend willst du sie nicht wegen den Stromkosten.
Anschließend willst du sie nicht, weil es zu laut ist.
Selbst wenn du einen Platz hast zum hinstellen.
Also im Prinzip kaufen und wieder wegschmeißen, oder wie?
Der Freundin zeigen, ja, die, also, Grills sind allgemein äußerst, kann man äußerst gut imponieren mit Oracle Tape Libraries.
Hab ich auch schon gemerkt.
Es ist immer das erste, worüber man spricht.
Und, was macht deine Tape Library?
Ah, ich habe jetzt eine neue Tape Library von Oracle.
Oh, ist das nice.
Typisches, typisches Gespräch, so wie das abläuft.
Vielleicht, wenn man eine Menge Solarenergie im Haus hat, ja.
Also, Reddit is happy.
Aber bei dem Typ, ich weiß es nicht.
LTO ist, glaube ich, die Art der Bänder, die da reinkommt.
Ach ja.
Und was bei so einer Tape Library ist?
Ach ja. Und was bei so einer Tape Library ist?
Auch so ein Ding ist.
Man sieht das, man muss sich das mal angucken im Betrieb.
Hier drinne sitzen ja letztendlich dann die Bänder.
Und das sieht richtig cool aus, wenn so ein Ding im Betrieb ist.
Zeig, ich zeige euch, ich zeige euch das mal.
Ich zeige euch, ich zeige euch das mal.
Für alle, die es noch nicht gesehen haben.
Tape Library Robot, Robotikarm.
So sieht das da drinne aus.
Das ist natürlich ne größere.
Das ist natürlich ne deutlich größere, wie das, was man gesehen hat.
Das ist so eine alte IBM Storage Tape.
tape library so ein ding so ein ding hatten wir früher wo ich noch beim
provider gearbeitet habe da hatten wir noch so fette ibm storage systeme also
schon lange lange lange da wo ich meine ausbildung gemacht habe lange her und
ich habe wirklich stunden insgesamt damit zugebracht wenn irgendwas im
rechenzentrum war nicht auf irgendwas gewartet habe hier rein zu gucken da ist
ein kleines fenster an der seite denn da sind keine da sind keine festplatten
das ist band das ist band ist das nicht super fehleranfällig das ist ja unter
anderem der grund warum die regelmäßig rotiert und gedreht werden dass es
zuverlässiger bleibt also auch wenn nichts da drauf passiert wird dieser ab
und zu und band rausnehmen drehen wieder einstecken dass es nicht festklebt das
ist
dass ein bänder sind das mit welchem programm beschreibt man das am besten
ich hab vergessen wir das heißt das ist irgend so den ibm wie hießen das war
das macht in mich gehen wie hieß das denn ich kenne das ibm gibt so ein
backup day von ibm backup als ich bin ich bin zu lange
nicht mehr in dem laden ich hab's vergessen wenn ich wenn ich sehe wie es
ist
ich es wieder. Tivoli! Tivoli! TSM ist das, genau. TSM. Ja, TSM. Der TSM-Command. Klein-Client
braucht man dafür. Zumindest war das früher TSM. Und ich habe da wirklich Stunden mit
zugebracht, wenn ich im Rechenzentrum gewartet habe, hier in dieses Fenster reinzugucken
und zuzuschauen, wie dieser Roboterarm dort irgendwelche Tapes rumsortiert. Was würde
beim Provider groß auf Tapes gespeichert? Es waren zwei Sachen, die auf Tape, also zwei
unterschiedliche Dinger gab es. Es gab einmal diese IBM-Tape-Library, die kommt als offizielle
Backup-Lösung bei IBM-Storage-Systemen mit, wenn man das haben will. Das ist quasi ein
Bundle aus Storage-Systemen. Da hast du dann halt so ein...
So eins, zwei, drei Racks vollstehen mit Festplatten drinnen. Und als Backup-Lösung
kommt so eine Tape-Library mit, wenn man die mitbestellt. Das ist quasi so, das wird quasi
so als Gesamtsystem verkauft, quasi Storage-System mit Langzeit-Backup-Archivierung. Das ist
quasi verbandelt. Da musst du meines Willens nach gar nicht so viel einstellen. Muss man
die auch mieten? Ne, die muss man kaufen. Die kosten glaube ich so 600.000, 700.000 Euro
so ein Bundle, je nach Ausstattung.
Oder sogar mehr. Also damals 600.000, 700.000 Euro. Also 2000, 2007 rum. Das kostet wahrscheinlich
mittlerweile 2, 3 Millionen oder so. Ich weiß gar nicht, ob es sowas noch gibt. Ja, und
die andere Sache, die auf Tape gespeichert wurde, das war dann aber nicht diese zum Storage-System
gehörige, glaube ich, waren irgendwelche Langzeit-Archivierungs-Backups von beispielsweise E-Mails oder irgendwelche
Dinger. Haben die damals da drauf gespeichert. Aber...
Also...
Es gab ja dann irgendwie so eine Vorgabe, dass du sowas irgendwie 10 Jahre aufbewahren
musst, wenn das irgendwelche Business-relevanten Daten enthält. Und das haben die auch auf
Tape gespeichert. Wie gesagt, 2007, 2008. Wie das jetzt ist, jetzt tippe ich mal drauf,
ist das eher nicht mehr so. Aber das hat wirklich, ohne Mist, Leute, das hat was super Meditierendes,
wenn ihr euch sowas anguckt. Ich konnte da echt, mal gucken, ob es noch ein besseres Video
gibt. Ich konnte da Stunden davor stehen.
Und mir das angucken. Ja, das ist so ein kleines Fenster an der Seite, genau. Ich konnte da
echt Stunden davor stehen, mir das angucken. Hat eigentlich, jetzt war eine blöde Frage,
Leute. Warum hat eigentlich jede Kamera diese Schriftart? Egal, ob es billige China-Chinesen-Kameras
sind, ob es teure Kameras sind, diese Schriftart. Und diese auf jede Kamera hat das On-Screen-
oder On-... Nee, nicht On-Screen. Wie nennt man das? On-Video-Overlay.
Ist diese Schriftart auf... Und diese Layouts... Warum? Gibt's da... Hat da irgendwie das
chinesische Welt-Webcam-Konsortium entschieden, dass alle Webcams weltweit so aussehen müssen?
Ministerium. Und alle halten sich dran. Jede Kamera sieht so aus. War Vorratsdatenspeicherung
schon ein Thema? Ja. Sind die Dinger laut? Eigentlich nicht. Das ist durch die Fenster und so geht das,
Man hört es ein bisschen rumpeln, aber das geht eigentlich, ja.
Also wie gesagt, ich werde euch nicht zu sehr mit altem Zeug schlangweilen,
aber das ist sowas von meditativ.
Jedes Mal, wenn ich im Rechenzentrum warten musste und nichts zu tun habe,
bin ich zu der Tape Library hingegangen und habe reingeguckt,
habe ein Fenster und wisst ihr, was noch cooler ist,
sich das im Dunkeln anzugucken?
Ich bin ja eh ein Fan von Rechenzentrum im Dunkeln.
Guck mal, Data Center in the Dark.
Ich weiß nicht, da war es, Dark, äh, ja.
Without Lights on, was soll ich denn da suchen?
Inside Data Center without Lights, ja.
Ja, hier sieht man es eigentlich ganz gut.
Das kommt auf dem Handy nicht so rüber.
Ich bin immer gerne morgens, wenn auch keiner da war,
und noch während meiner Ausbildung damals auch,
da hatten wir drei verschiedene Rechenzentren,
durch die man morgens durchlaufen musste in Frankfurt,
und einfach mal gucken.
Ob noch alles steht, war so gut wie nie was, ja.
Und da ist man durchgelaufen, und ich habe immer das Licht ausgelassen.
Ich glaube, offiziell durfte man das nicht,
wegen Sicherheitsvorkehrungen, sonst haut man sich den Kopf,
rennt irgendwo dagegen, aber ich habe trotzdem das Licht ausgelassen.
Ich bin dann da rein, das Licht ging nicht automatisch,
du musstest immer einen Schalter drücken, habe ich nicht,
ich habe das Licht absichtlich ausgelassen,
und bin immer im Dunkeln durchs Rechenzentrum gelaufen.
Und ich fand das richtig entspannend,
morgens nochmal durchs dunkle Rechenzentrum zu laufen.
Und ich konnte euch damals sagen,
in allen drei Rechenzentren konnte ich euch sagen,
wenn heute eine Warnlampe irgendwo geleuchtet hat,
die gestern noch nicht geleuchtet hat,
richtiger Gangster, ja, richtiger Gangster läuft beim Dunkeln durchs Rechenzentrum.
Okay, das ist auch ein Video aufgenommen mit Technik von vor 35...
Okay, vor zwölf Jahren, da ist mir das gefallen.
Ups, nein, nein, wir gucken jetzt nicht da.
Nein, nein, nein.
Ja, so sieht es aus.
Ja, und ich vermute, dass das hier bei seiner Tape Library auch im Rahmen passiert,
allerdings nicht so, nicht so groß.
Ich weiß nicht, ob das Ding auch einen Roboterarm hat, eher nicht.
Doch, hat einen Roboterarm, guck, ja, glaube ich.
Ansonsten kann ich nur hin und her fahren und Tapes rumschieben.
Zumindest, ich wüsste wirklich nicht, was ich mit einer Tape Library daheim mache.
So, GitHub, lass mal kurz gucken, was auf GitHub so...
Oh, guck mal, hier hat jemand meinen VM-Champ geforkt und vor zwei Monaten geupdatet.
Kevin, was ist da los?
Er hat GitHub Actions improved.
Richtig krasser Dude, der Kevin hier.
Was macht der denn hier so? Package Build.
Oh, hat er das vielleicht sogar als...
...als Issue aufgemacht und ich habe es nie gesehen?
Ne, okay, gut.
Hätte er sein können.
Ja, alles klar, was trennet denn auf GitHub?
Auf GitHub heute.
Ah, wo ist es denn?
Hä?
Gab es da nicht immer einen Knopf normalerweise hier oben rechts für?
Für Trending?
Wo ist denn der hin?
Ah, hier.
Oh, so ist Trending, da ist er.
Auf dem Handy ist er oben rechts.
Also, zeigt mal her, was trennet denn diese Woche?
Ich werde mal wieder das ganze AI Zeug skippen, weil das ist eh voll.
Okay, AI, AI, AI, AI, AI.
Neowim, okay.
Open Source Alternative to Google Sheets Slides.
Das ist quasi ein Office written in TypeScript sozusagen, oder?
Punkt AI, was sonst?
Was würde man sonst bei einem Office im Browser erwarten als eine Punkt AI Domain?
Zeigt mal her.
Live Demos.
Sheets.
Ist das nur eine Alternative zu Sheets?
Slides?
Docs?
Aha.
Wow, das kommt auf jeden Fall mit meinem Dark wieder nicht zurecht.
Aha, okay.
Eine Google, aber, also, ja gut, wenn man das vielleicht sich selbst hosten will daheim,
oder?
Nice, dass es Alternativen gibt.
Ich, ihr wisst, ich bin kein Fan von Office Produkten allgemein, also für mich ist das
nix.
Helix, okay.
Text Editor AI.
CAD Software written in Rust.
Blazingly Fast, selbstverständlich, was sonst?
Äh, CAC 3D.
The Programming Language Compiled to Bash.
Okay, was ist das?
Das ist tatsächlich mal was Interessantes.
Habe ich noch nie was von gehört.
Programming Language Compiled to Bash.
Was es nicht alles gibt.
It's a high level programming language that makes it easy to create shell scripts.
Okay.
Beispiel?
So ein Example wäre schon cool, oder?
Wisst ihr, das finde ich immer blöd.
Gerade bei Programmiersprachen finde ich so ein fünf Zeilen Hello World immer richtig
aussagekräftig auf so einer, auf so einer Readme-Seite, so wie sie es hier haben.
Es ist quasi Bash nur mit besserer Syntax.
Sehe ich das richtig?
Eigentlich, eigentlich eine coole Sache, oder?
Ich glaube, das müssen wir tatsächlich mal ausprobieren.
Nicht jetzt.
Das ist im Prinzip ein bisschen so was wie TypeScript zu JavaScript.
Das finde ich nice.
Das finde ich ganz spannend.
Da bin ich mal gespannt.
Haben die noch ein paar bisschen mehr Beispiele?
Docs.
Das scheint mir relativ...
Alter.
Halt es echt.
Ich muss was trinken.
Erst mal kurz gucken.
Das gibt es auch noch nicht so lange hier.
Schaut mal.
Guck mal.
Das gibt es seit...
By the way.
Warum eigentlich?
Why?
Warum ist das eigentlich auf GitLab so richtig, auf GitHub so richtig dumm gemacht?
Mit diesem, dass man nicht gescheit zum Anfang kommt?
Warum gibt es hier keine Seiten unten?
Beziehungsweise, wenn mal Endlesscroll sinnvoll wäre, dann Endlesscroll.
Ja, vor zwei Jahren.
Lass mal kurz noch ein paar Beispiele angucken.
Okay.
Guck mal, es gibt sogar eine Visual Studio Code Extension.
Alpha ist es.
Ja, was anderes hätte ich jetzt auch nicht erwartet.
Ein bisschen mehr Beispiele wäre eigentlich ganz cool.
Getting started.
Echo.
Hello World.
Sieht aus wie ein Bash.
Installation.
Usage.
Basic Syntax.
Aha, hier sehen wir ein paar Beispiele.
Let name gleich John.
Let age.
Benutzt das?
Was mich jetzt interessieren würde, ist das, was da am Ende rauskommt.
Ist das pures Bash?
Oder ruft der auch Kommandos, die höchstwahrscheinlich da sind, auf?
Also sowas wie ein Set oder so.
Oder ein AWK oder ein Grep.
Also alle, sagen wir mal, Standardkommandos, auf die man sich eigentlich verlassen kann, dass sie da sind.
Ruft der die auch auf?
Weil das würde es natürlich viel, viel, ja, besser usable machen alles.
Und mal ganz davon abgesehen, man braucht ja auch die Möglichkeit, weil ohne externe Kommandos,
ist ein Bash-Skript ja kein Bash-Skript.
Also sagen wir mal, wenn ich jetzt hier zum Beispiel eine Datei öffnen will und darin was
gappen.
Wie macht man das?
Das hier ist ja alles Build-In.
Aber 99% aller Shell-Skripts sind irgendwelche Sachen öffnen, auslesen, filtern und sowas.
Das heißt, ohne das ist das komplett nice to have.
Aber...
Man kann nichts damit anfangen.
Kann man da auch externe Commands aufrufen?
Hier, Commands.
Ach hier, okay, Move.
Man macht einen Dollar davor.
Das MV fällt.
Das ist eine coole Syntax.
Das finde ich nice, guck mal.
Das finde ich eigentlich ganz cool gemacht.
So nach quasi einem automatischen If.
Also in Bash würde man sowas, kann man ja sowas machen, ja.
Also sagen wir mal, hier irgendein Kommando.
Setze ein Kommando ein, was funktioniert.
Ich habe es hier noch in meiner History drin stehen, ja.
So ähnlich könnte man sowas hier in Bash schreiben.
So nach dem Motto, Kommando was funktioniert.
Wenn dieses Kommando funktioniert, dann okay.
Ansonsten Fehler.
Wenn man hier reinclap falls, kommt Fehler raus.
Also sagen wir mal sowas hier.
Echo 1, das geht immer.
Und das hier gibt es nicht.
Fehler.
Also man kann sowas auch schon in Bash machen.
Das ist so ein taktisch, natürlich deutlich schicker.
Wenn man sowas 1 zu 1 in Bash machen will, ohne diesen Shortcut, ja.
Dann müsste man sowas hier zum Beispiel machen.
Echo 1.
Und dann testen zum Beispiel $?
$? ist in Bash immer der Exit Code des letzten Kommands.
Also Echo 1 ist mit dem Exit Code 0 rausgegangen.
Jetzt machen wir mal sowas hier wie das da, was es nicht gibt.
Exit Code, sagt die Shell, das war Exit Code 127.
Weil, ja, gab es nicht.
Also das ist natürlich schon.
Und dann müsste man da quasi ein if machen.
If das da equals 0 und so.
Aber da ist das schon schöner.
Auf der anderen Seite kann man sich jetzt ja fragen.
Wenn man mit Bash schon eine recht umfangreiche Script Umgebung, Environment hat.
Und damit alles aufrufen kann und machen kann, was man will.
Warum braucht man da noch Ember?
Der einzige Vorteil, den ich sehe, ist halt, dass die Bash Syntax oftmals nicht so schön ist.
Dafür hat man sich an die Bash Syntax gewöhnt.
Und kann Bash Syntax auch halbwegs gut aus dem Kopf, wenn man das schon eine Weile macht.
Bei Ember muss man sich wieder komplett an was Neues gewöhnen.
Also ich würde mal aktuell eher sagen, das ist so ein Experimental Ding.
Was was guten Ansatz hat.
Aber man sehen muss, wohin sich das führt.
Wohin sich das entwickelt.
Mich würde mal interessieren, wie so dann ein Compilter Output aussieht.
Skippen wir mal das Ganze hier.
Advanced Syntax.
Compiler Flags.
Finde ich cool.
Das gucken wir uns mal an.
Nicht das hier.
Das hier.
Ich bin noch nicht so ganz überzeugt von der Sinnhaftigkeit.
Oder sagen wir mal so der Alltagstauglichkeit im Endeffekt.
Ob das überhaupt so viel Sinn macht.
Beispiele Outputs auf der Homepage.
Also ich will noch ein bisschen unterschätzen, ob das Sinn macht.
Aber es ist auf jeden Fall eines der interessantesten Sachen, die ich in letzter Zeit in den Github Trends gefunden habe.
Wo ist hier ein Output?
Ach hier.
Write.
If age unter 18.
Kleiner 18.
Und das Ganze wird dann Compiled zu.
Alles klar.
Da sehe ich schon wieder ein Problem drinnen.
Wenn da doch sagen wir mal rechts.
Unleserliches Bash bei rauskommt.
Dass man die Scripts ja nicht als Ember beispielsweise auf dem Server verteilen würde.
Sondern als Compiled Bash Output.
Und jemand der dann auf den Server geht und nachgucken will.
Und dieses Bash Script aufmacht.
Wird das absolut nicht verstehen.
Weil der Compiler Output wohl sehr unleserlich ist.
Niemand würde das so schreiben normalerweise.
Und ich bin mir noch nicht mal sicher.
Das überhaupt.
Ach der macht einen BC dann da draus.
Alter.
Das ist ja.
Das ist ja glaube ich so ziemlich das unbeständlichste If.
Was ich mir vorstellen kann.
Um zu checken ob age kleiner 13 ist.
Der könnte auch einfach sagen.
Dollar age.
Less than 18.
Das wäre doch die schönere Wahl.
Also.
Das ist natürlich blöd.
Wenn irgendjemand dann auf dem Server über dein Shell Script stolpert.
Kann das keine Sau mehr lesen.
Das spricht schon mal dagegen.
Also.
Die Idee ist was dieses Shell Script macht.
Anstatt einfach das Shell Script in einem Editor aufzumachen.
Oder im Less aufzumachen auf dem Server.
Musst du dann gucken wo kommt das Shell Script her.
Und dir den ursprünglichen Ember Code dafür angucken.
Weiterer Punkt.
Wo ich sagen würde.
Das ist nicht so praktikabel.
Coole Idee.
Erstmal habe ich es für eine sehr sinnvolle Sache gehalten.
Aber jetzt umso länger ich darüber nachdenke.
Bin ich unschlüssig wie sinnvoll das Ganze ist.
Ja gut.
Das ist auf jeden Fall ein spannendes Project.
Gibt es da auch einen Decompiler für.
Ich glaube.
Wenn überhaupt noch keiner.
Also kannst du sicherlich.
Das du quasi Bash to Ember machst.
Wobei ich mir vorstellen könnte.
Das Bash to Ember gar nicht so ohne weiteres geht.
Weil du bestimmt in Bash.
Aktuell mehr machen kannst.
Als Ember unterstützt.
Als 1 zu 1 so mappbar ist.
Also zum Beispiel.
Wie würde ein Decompiler.
Hier.
Less than 18 machen.
Wenn Ember das nicht kann.
Ich glaube.
Das ist fast ein Ding der Unmöglichkeit.
Sowas umgedrehtes zu bauen.
Solange du keine.
Dependencies hast.
Sobald du Dependencies hast.
Ist Python Handling kompletter Crap.
Also wenn du beispielsweise.
Ein Python Script baust.
Was 2-3 Libraries als Dependency braucht.
Kannst du vergessen.
Das kannst du nicht distributen.
Das funktioniert nicht.
Wenn du eine Web Anwendung damit gebaut hast.
Mit irgendeinem Deployment Step.
Wo dann passende Verzeichnis raus.
Alles Dings.
Danach läuft irgendwie ein VN.
Wo dann die Sachen mit rein.
Das kannst du nicht als Bash Ersatz verwenden.
Sobald du Dependencies hast.
Oder du musst anstatt ein Script.
Einfach in den Ordner verteilen.
Mit 16 Dateien drin.
Schrot.
Also Bash hat schon seine Daseinsberechtigung.
Immer noch.
Im einfachen.
Relativ übersichtlichen Bereich.
Wenn es da was zu automatisieren gibt.
Würde ich sogar argumentieren.
Das Bash ist das beste was man verwenden kann.
Meinetwegen PowerShell unter Windows.
Wenn es sein muss.
Und nicht PowerShell unter Linux.
Auch wenn es das gibt.
Jaja das meine ich nicht.
Wenn du Library Dependencies brauchst.
Sagen wir mal du brauchst.
Ist ein YAML Parser.
Standardmäßig in Python drin.
Aber gehen wir mal davon aus.
Und du willst YAML Dateien parsen.
Brauchst diese Library als Dependency.
Dann wird das Verteilen deines Python Scripts.
Absolut zum Albtraum.
Im Vergleich zu einem Bash Script.
Weil in einem Bash Script.
Würde ich ja auch nicht wirklich YAML parsen.
Sondern ich würde einfach.
Irgendwie ein bisschen tricksen mit.
Crap Datei sowieso.
Geh zwei Zeilen nach oben und mach das und das.
Aber das dann wiederum in Python zu machen.
Ist schon ein bisschen eklig.
Das hat seine Daseinsberechtigung.
Aber ich finde.
Wenn es ein Automatisierungstask ist.
Ja oder irgendwie so ein.
Maintenance Con Script.
Was irgendwas machen soll.
Da ist Bash einfach ungeschlagen.
Und es ist immer noch einfacher.
Kommandos auszuführen.
In irgendeinem Bash Script.
Anstelle in Python.
Irgendwie sowas wie System Run.
Oder wie heißt.
Wie macht man das mittlerweile.
Pipe Open oder sowas.
Ist doch glaube ich mittlerweile das richtige.
Nach Regex Dings.
Das ist alles nicht so das.
Also für einfache Automatisierungstask.
Ist und bleibt.
Bash.
Für meinen Geschmack.
Immer noch das beste.
So was haben wir sonst noch hier in den Trends.
AI.
Ich habe keine Ahnung.
Was überhaupt das sein soll.
Was?
Das ist eine Projektbeschreibung.
Die mir sowas von nichts sagt.
Krypto.
Kryptostells.
AI.
Power Toys.
Java Interview Questions.
Das ist tatsächlich ein guter Punkt.
Ja.
John da gebe ich dir Recht.
Das kann durchaus sein.
Das wird aber genauso gut oder schlecht funktionieren.
Wie bei anderen Programmiersprachen.
Bei einfachen Sachen.
Funktioniert das manchmal erstaunlich gut.
Aber die Fehler liegen dann in Details.
Aber bei mir ist das schon.
Ich habe das ein paar mal probiert.
Und.
Auch wenn es jetzt besser geworden ist.
Also ich habe GPT 4.
O.
Oder wie man es korrekt jetzt nennt.
Noch nicht ausprobiert damit.
Aber.
Ich war da nicht so sonderlich begeistert von.
Erkläre ChatGPT was du haben willst.
Und ChatGPT macht das.
Das erste Mal wo ich es ausprobiert habe.
Aber das war noch ChatGPT 3.5.
War sogar hier im Stream.
Und da habe ich mir gedacht.
Wollen wir mal in .NET in C Sharp.
Ein Kommandozeilen Tool bauen.
Oder eine Kommandozeilen Anwendung erstellen.
Die eine Datei downloadet.
Und eine Download Progress Bar anzeigt.
Das ist.
Wenn man das schon mal gemacht hat.
Eigentlich ziemlich easy.
Was ChatGPT gemacht hat.
Ist komplett nebendran gewesen.
Das hat Methoden erfunden.
Die es nicht gibt.
So nach dem Motto.
ChatGPT hat sich dazu.
Halluziniert.
So Dinger wie.
Http Client.
On Progress Event.
Die das überhaupt nicht hatte.
Und dann habe ich ChatGPT gesagt.
Das gibt es überhaupt nicht.
Dann meinte ChatGPT.
Ah ja tut mir leid.
Das ich falsch gelegen habe.
Hier neuer Versuch.
Und da kam eine Windows Forms Anwendung.
Und die hat gesagt.
Anstatt ein CLI Tool.
Auch mit Sachen die es nicht gibt.
Also.
Seitdem ist das bei mir.
Ein bisschen unten durch.
Aber für solche Sachen.
Nehme ich dir recht.
Für solche einfachen Sachen.
Kann das durchaus ganz gut funktionieren.
Wo das auch ganz gut ist.
Ansible und sowas verstehen.
Ansible kapiert ChatGPT.
Wirklich ganz brauchbar.
Und wofür ChatGPT richtig gut ist.
Ist.
Ist YAML Syntax.
Weil.
YAML Syntax.
Ist oftmals.
Ne das muss ich anders sagen.
Oder sag.
YAML Syntax ist oftmals richtig.
Obwohl sie falsch ist.
Versteht man was ich meine.
Nehmen wir mal irgendwie ein YAML Beispiel.
kekel.yaml
Ihr habt jetzt hier irgendwie sowas.
Ich denke mir jetzt einfach mal.
Random irgendwas aus.
Ja.
Wie sowas wie hier.
Kamera oder so.
So und dann habt ihr Name.
Lul.
So und dann habt ihr sowas wie.
Source für das Bild.
Und dann unter Source.
Müsst ihr dann zum Beispiel schreiben.
Hier URL.
RTSP bla bla bla bla.
Und dann schreibt ihr sowas wie.
Passwort.
123456.
So und jetzt haben wir ein Problem.
Das hier ist syntaktisch.
Korrektes YAML.
Aber logisch ist es falsch.
Weil Passwort muss dahin.
Und nicht dahin.
Ja.
Aber syntaktisch ist das YAML richtig.
Das heißt ein YAML Syntax Checker.
Wird nicht erkennen dass ihr hier irgendwas verkackt habt.
Also ein reiner.
Ohne Schema und sonst was.
Ein reiner YAML Syntax Checker.
Sagt vollkommen in Ordnung.
Korrektes YAML.
Okay vielleicht sagt es das hier nicht.
Unschlüssig vielleicht muss man das quoten.
Egal wie das schraubt.
So oder so.
Das würde ich sagen.
Allerdings muss man da.
Wenn man das in ChatGPT reinhaut.
Und sagt hey ChatGPT.
Ich habe hier ein.
Kubernetes Manifest.
Das geht nicht.
Mit dieser und dieser Fehlermeldung.
Da ist ChatGPT richtig gut drin sowas zu erkennen.
Da sagt er.
Ist doch klar warum das nicht geht.
Weil die Einrückung bei Passwort falsch ist.
Sagt er nicht wirklich ich weiß.
Oder man kann das fragen.
Hier ich habe diesen Output hier.
Und den kannst du dann ausprobieren.
Dafür ist das wirklich gut.
Sofern es.
Irgendwas ist.
Wo es die Logik dahinter.
Gelernt hat.
Also.
Ich nenne es mal Syntax Fehler.
Auch wenn es keine YAML Syntax Fehler sind.
Für sowas ist ChatGPT wirklich nice.
Und auch für Ansible Playbooks.
Wo solche Dinger manchmal passieren können.
Da ist ChatGPT auch nice.
Oder für JSON Output.
Für sowas in der Richtung.
Wo es dann ein bisschen mehr ist.
Als reines Syntax checken.
Sondern auch ein bisschen die Logik darüber checken.
Da ist ChatGPT wirklich sehr hilfreich.
Für.
Lasst mal die.
Wir sind mittlerweile schon bei YOLO V10.
Ich habe mal Bilderkennung gemacht.
Haben wir das nicht sogar im Stream gemacht?
Mit YOLO Bilderkennung.
Das war noch V3.
Ich habe keinen Plan.
Was das überhaupt sein soll.
Anhand der Projektbeschreibung.
This is where to use.
In any enterprise.
What?
Ah.
AI.
Ok.
Das war ja diesmal wirklich 80% AI.
Lass uns nochmal schnell gucken.
Was so im .NET Ökosystem trendet.
Maui.
Ich warte ja noch jeden Tag auf den Blogpost.
Dass Maui endlich eingestellt wird.
Aspire.
Ok.
Browslin.
Stabil.
Source Game.
Code Generator.
HTTP Code.
Wenn man OpenAPI.
JSON hat.
Ja das kennen wir auch schon.
Bulk Crap Insta Uninstaller.
Das ist was für Windows.
Moment.
Warum ist .NET Reactive?
Warum braucht das eine Future?
Ist das nicht mal Future genug?
Bulk Crap Installer.
Remove large amounts of unwanted applications quickly.
Ok.
Wisst ihr was das Beste ist?
Um unwanted applications quickly zu removen.
Das Beste ist ja mal unwanted applications erst gar nicht installiert.
Ja ich gebe zu.
Das ist unter Windows 11 schwierig geworden.
Weil Windows 11 mit jeder Menge unwanted shit kommt.
Was ist Aspire?
Das ist.
Ein.
Boah frag mich bitte nicht wie Microsoft das nennt.
Das ist ein Tool.
Um OpenTelemetry zu visualisieren.
Und zu integrieren.
In deine .NET Anwendung.
Inklusive Dashboard und sowas.
Dass du nicht mal so viel Zusatz Tools brauchst.
Ich kann es dir auch nur erklären.
So.
Ja.
Wäre schlecht als recht.
Weil ich nur mal ein paar Videos zugeguckt habe.
Und es selbst noch nicht ausprobiert habe.
Also.
Du kannst wohl deine .NET Core Anwendung.
Deine .NET ASP .NET Core Anwendung.
Kannst du wohl.
Relativ easy mit einem Dashboard ausstatten.
Mit Matrix ausstatten.
Mit OpenTelemetry Tracing ausstatten.
Quasi inklusive inklusive Dashboard.
Und Logging.
Overview.
Ohne das du beispielsweise Grafana installieren musst.
OpenTelemetry Collector.
Also sprich wenn du einfach nur deine Anwendung.
Ein bisschen.
Überwachen willst.
In haben möchtest.
Dann kann man .NET Aspire benutzen.
Wie genau?
Keine Ahnung.
Ich habe es noch nicht ausprobiert.
Nee.
Ich frage mich immer noch.
Warum .NET Reactive.
Keine Future hat.
Ich dachte das ist eigentlich relativ beliebt.
Ich habe das auch schon ein paar mal verwendet.
Okay.
Das hieß vor 2 Weeks.
Vor 2 Weeks hat das Dings.
Ich werde es irgendwann anders mal durchlesen.
Warum das jetzt so viel nicer ist.
Oder ist das ein reines Unity Ding.
Okay. Keine Ahnung.
Das gucken wir uns jetzt nicht an.
Mal nachher anschauen ob das irgendwie sinnig ist.
Der Typ hat übrigens relativ viele.
Bekannte Libraries am Start.
Der kommt mir bekannt vor.
Gut.
Ja waren ja tatsächlich dieses Mal ein paar ganz interessanter Sachen.
In den Trends drinne.
Why Modern UI is Amazing.
Ich muss euch ehrlich sagen.
Jedes des modernen UIs.
Finde ich zu tabletisiert.
Zu Mobile Interface.
Auf dem Desktop.
Ganz Youtube.
Youtube und Youtube ist doch eines der besseren Seiten.
Ganz Youtube schreiten Mobile Seite.
Auch auf dem Desktop.
Allein schon das hier.
Dieses dumme nervige Endlesscroll.
Anstatt Seiten.
Oh da.
Da schläfst du ja ein bei.
Ja.
Also ich will nicht abstreiten.
Weil das UI Design.
Durchaus optisch.
Viel besser ist.
Ja.
Vieles damals.
Was ich an modernem UI Design nicht mag ist.
Das man.
Das sich die Anwendung auf dem Desktop.
Und die Website auf dem Desktop.
Oftmals so Mobile mäßig anfühlen.
Auch mit so einem Shit wie Endlesscroll.
Oder.
Überschreiben von Browser Funktionen.
Der schlimmste Offender.
Meiner Meinung nach.
Ich hab's ja schon öfters mal gesagt.
Hier.
Diese Forum Software.
Ich weiß nicht ist das Discurs.
Oder wie auch immer man das nennt.
Ich finde das vom Handling her einfach so.
So eklig.
Diese Forum Software.
Machen wir mal hier irgendwie mal.
Mal was auf.
So guck mal.
Sieht ja erstmal gar nicht so schlimm aus.
Sieht ja erstmal.
Eigentlich ganz normal nach Forum aus.
Und so.
Dass du hier nichts drinnen suchen kannst.
Wenn du anfängst hier drinnen zu suchen.
Überschreibt es die Browser Suchfunktion.
Mit so einer Bildinnsuche.
Und.
Wenn man sich das hier anguckt.
Das Scrollen auf der Seite scrollt auch gar nicht.
Sondern.
Lädt im Prinzip einfach nur nach.
Das heißt im Endeffekt.
Hier ordentlich, ordentlich hoch und runter scrollen.
Funktioniert gar nicht mehr richtig.
Auf solchen Seiten.
Nur mit diesem komischen Ding.
Und es buggt die ganze Zeit rum.
Und.
Um euch jetzt.
Ähm.
Bisschen Geflame da drüber zu ersparen.
Ne das geht nicht.
Was geht ist hier oben reinklicken und search.
Das Problem ist nur.
Das bringt ja nichts.
Weil es ist ja gar nicht alles geladen.
Das sind ja nur 10 Posts oder so geladen.
Und ich verstehe den Sinn.
Ja schön.
Aber bringt halt nichts.
Das hier unten ist beispielsweise gar nicht geladen.
Wenn ich hier oben bin.
Das war noch nicht mal gescheit.
Obwohl es einen Link da gibt.
Darauf verlinken kann.
Sei mal dahingestellt oder bookmarken.
Man kann hier das da drauf verlinken.
Zumindest.
Jaja ich weiß.
Man kann hier in dem Thread suchen dann irgendwas.
My Bad oder so.
Aber ganz ehrlich.
Das ist eine Sache die nervt mich.
Warum muss man Browserfunktionen in schlecht nachbauen.
Zumindest ansatzweise.
Verstehe ich.
Dass man sowas auf Mobile macht.
Wobei ich ehrlich sagen muss.
Selbst auf Mobile.
Sind die Geräte heutzutage.
Die meisten.
Stark genug.
Auch längere Webseiten zu laden.
Aber man muss.
Man muss auch auf Mobile nicht nach.
3 Posts.
Weiterladen.
Das ist nicht notwendig.
Und es ist auch enorm schwierig.
Wiederzufinden.
Wenn ich sage.
Ah ok ich weiß genau.
Der hat vor ein paar Tagen.
Hat da einer was drauf gepostet.
Auf Seite 17.
Gibt ja keine Seiten mehr.
Und das Ding was ich nicht verstehe ist.
Also wie gesagt.
Mobile irgendwie geht es noch.
Aber auf dem Desktop.
Fühlt sich das so fremd an diese Bedienung.
Ihr seht das ja hier.
Ich denke dann zurück dran.
Das war dann meistens.
Solche Dinger wie.
Kennt ihr mal noch diese alten.
PHP Foren.
So My Bulletin.
Und PHP Bulletin.
Die damals noch Lizenzgebühren gekostet haben.
Das war auch nicht toll.
Ich sage nicht das das toll war.
Keine Frage.
My C Sharp zum Beispiel.
So ein richtig olles Forum glaube ich.
Wo ich früher auch mal ein bisschen drin.
Aktiv war.
Die haben noch so ein richtig olles.
Wobei die das auch schon ein bisschen aktualisiert haben.
Ist auch schon ein bisschen moderneres Forum.
Kennt noch einer.
Irgendeine Seite mit so einem richtig.
Ollen Forum.
So ein richtig altes.
Mox Mox Forum.
Das.
Das Mikrocontroller Forum.
Most toxic Forum.
Auf diesem Planeten.
Ja sowas hier.
Ne nehmen wir mal hier irgendwas mit.
107 Posts.
Guckt mal.
Wo ist das Problem.
Es ist doch nicht so als braucht das sonderlich viel Speicher.
Ich kann doch ohne Probleme.
107 Posts.
Laden.
Das ist doch kein Ding.
Das schafft doch ein aktueller Rechner.
Mit 32, 64 Gig RAM.
Und einem modernen Browser.
Ein bisschen Text zu laden.
Und man kann ja auch durchaus.
Vielleicht ne neue Seite machen oder sowas.
Aber das ist schnell.
Das ist easy.
Das sieht nicht schön aus.
Das liegt aber nicht daran das das nicht gehen würde.
Sondern einfach weil das Forum alt ist.
Wisst ihr also.
Ich bevorzuge auf dem Desktop.
Eine Webseite die sich wie eine Webseite anfühlt.
Versus eine Webseite die sich anfühlt.
Wie eine Mobile Anwendung.
Und das ist das.
Was mir an modernem Design nicht gefällt.
Nicht die Optik.
Chat.
Ich weiß nicht wie ihr das seht.
Was findet ihr optisch schöner.
Ich mach mal kurz den Darkreader raus.
Das Home Assistant Forum.
Oder das Mikrocontroller Forum.
Also rein vom Design her.
Finde ich das hier schöner.
Weil.
Schönere Schriftart.
Weicheres Fontrendering.
Abstände schöner und sowas.
Finde ich das optisch.
Design mäßig finde ich das hier schöner.
Usability technisch.
Übersichtlich.
Von der Übersichtlichkeit her.
Finde ich das hier um Längen besser.
Ich könnte mir fast vorstellen das es um Datenbankrequests geht.
Ja vielleicht.
Aber es ist ja nicht schlimm.
Da macht man einfach.
Anstatt Get Top 10.
Macht man halt Get Top 200.
Das ging ja schon vor 20 Jahren.
In alten PHP Foren ohne Probleme.
Und dann ist gut.
Also mir ist das hier deutlich lieber.
Nicht das Mikrocontroller Forum im Speziellen.
Das ist Shit.
Das ist.
Abschaum das Mikrocontroller Forum.
Oder zumindest.
Einige Posts da drinnen.
Und Leute da drinnen.
Aber.
Von der Usability her.
Finde ich deutlich.
Finde ich deutlich besser.
Und bevor ich jetzt ohne Begründung.
Über das Mikrocontroller Forum flame.
Ich versuche ich das mal zu begründen.
Also eines der Sachen.
Die mich bei Foren.
Nicht nur dem Mikrocontroller Forum.
Bei allen Foren.
So bei diesen allen Oldschool Foren.
Immer extrem getriggert hat.
Ist wenn dort irgendjemand was postet.
Es gibt zwei Möglichkeiten.
Irgendjemand postet was.
Machen wir es einfach.
Es postet einer was.
Zum Beispiel.
Hey Leute.
Ich habe einen ESP32.
Ne.
Wie heißen diese Dinger.
DS18.
DS1 also.
Stellt euch mal vor.
Es macht einer dort ein Forum.
Leute ich habe einen ESP32.
Und möchte gerne.
Daran einen DS18B20 Temperatursensor betreiben.
Ich habe alles.
Angelötet.
Ich habe alles angelötet.
Aber.
Beim Auslesen.
Des Sensors.
Manchmal falsche Werte.
So das ist eine Frage in dem Forum.
Das habe ich mir jetzt ausgedacht.
Frage in dem Forum.
Und sagen wir mal.
Er postet sogar seinen Source Code mit.
So nach dem Motto.
Hier ist mein Source Code zum Auslesen.
Er macht sogar noch ein Foto von dem Board.
Dann gibt es.
Dann kommt als erste Antwort.
Warum verwendest du so einen scheiß Sensor.
Der Sensor ist überhaupt nicht dafür da.
Was du machen willst.
Und dann antwortet er.
Ich brauche einen wasserdichten Autosensor.
Dafür ist er doch genau gut.
Nein.
Dieser Sensor ist Schrott.
Ich verwende immer BME280.
So komplett random Antwort kommt dann.
War schon mal nicht hilfreich.
Okay.
Nächste Antwort die dann kommt ist.
Ja.
Du musst an der und der Stelle.
Musst in Widerstand rein.
Das ist elektrotechnisch kompletter Schrott.
Was du gebaut hast.
Wenn du in Widerstand drin bist.
Dann explodiert dein Klo.
Wenn du das nächste mal drauf gehst.
Dann sagt er.
Aber ich krieg doch zu 90% ordentliche Werte.
Also das Auslesen funktioniert doch.
Das ist doch überhaupt kein Problem.
Daran kann es doch nicht liegen.
Ja mach das erstmal richtig.
Ich habe das gelernt.
So wie du das gebaut hast.
Das ist richtiger Kack.
Das kann ja gar nicht funktionieren.
Der nächste kommt an.
Ja aber das sind doch nur 3 Zeilen.
Das gibt es da einzurücken.
Nein also dann kannst du nicht erwarten.
Das andere Leute sich mit deinem Problem befassen.
Wenn du schon nicht die Zeit investierst.
Deinen Code richtig einzurücken.
Ignore.
Ich ignoriere jetzt diesen Thread.
Ich weiß woran es liegt.
Aber ich helfe dir nicht.
Ja so.
Hast du dann solche Antworten drin?
Ja.
So im Endeffekt war sein Problem einfach nur.
Er hat ein 5 Meter Kabel genommen.
Anstatt ein 2 Meter Kabel.
Und deswegen hat er manchmal Übertragungsfehler.
Was aber keiner.
Achja und spätestens ab dem 10 Post.
Also allerspätestens ab dem 10 Post.
Drifte die Diskussion eh ab.
Zwischen 2 Leuten.
Die sich über was komplett anderes betteln.
Als das um was es in diesem Thread geht.
Also zum Beispiel.
Der Typ der geschrieben hat.
Du brauchst dort einen Widerstand.
Aber kommt da eine Antwort drauf.
Nein.
Du brauchst keinen Widerstand an der Stelle.
Du kannst auch einfach hier.
Pull up whatever.
Keine Ahnung.
Ergibt keinen Sinn.
Ich weiß.
Aktivieren im Microcontroller.
Dann kommt der erste Typ wieder.
Nein du hast keine Ahnung.
Du hast sicherlich noch nie sowas gebaut.
Du brauchst da mindestens ein.
Keine Ahnung.
100 Ohm Widerstand.
Leitungsdurchmesser.
Auf dieser Länge.
Muss es mindestens 1 Kilo Ohm Resistor sein.
Und der nächste ist.
Doch ich hab das schon so gebaut.
So und dann sind die super Sidetracked.
Und am Endeffekt sind sie sich nach 300 Posts einig.
Das es ein 471,8 Ohm Widerstand sein muss.
Das das ganze funktionieren kann.
Und in Wirklichkeit ist eigentlich das Problem.
Von dem Typ gewesen.
Das sein Kabel ein paar Zentimeter zu lang ist.
Und das Mikrocontroller Forum.
Deswegen Leute.
Ihr könnt wenn ihr was sucht.
Wenn ihr was sucht auf Google.
Und ihr findet das Mikrocontroller Forum.
Dann kann man durchaus da mal durchscrollen.
Da stehen die ein oder anderen hilfreichen Sachen drin.
Aber kommt nicht auf die Idee eine Frage stellen zu wollen.
Und kommt auch nicht auf die Idee.
Threads länger als die ersten paar Posts.
Irgendwie zu durchforsten.
Das ist.
Das ist verschwendete Zeit.
Und eine Sache hab ich auch gemerkt.
Was bei diesen Foren auch sehr interessant ist.
Sobald jemand das macht.
Was gefordert wird.
Gibt es keine Antworten mehr drauf.
Zum Beispiel.
Der gleiche Typ.
Zum Entertainment kann man das lesen.
Der gleiche Typ postet das.
Und die Antwort ist.
Ja du hast ja dein Code gar nicht richtig eingerückt.
Sag mal ist Vodafone wieder am abkacken.
Hat es gerade geruckelt.
Chat.
Was ist hier los.
Vodafone.
Ich hab es genau in meiner Vorschau gesehen.
Was ist da wieder los Vodafone.
Es ist auch ein Anbieter.
Was ein Schrott.
Ne ne ne.
Sonntag morgens hat Vodafone öfters mal so kleine Ruckler.
Zumindest um mein Beispiel jetzt fertig abzuschließen.
Da postet einer ihm.
Ja dann rück doch mal deinen Code richtig ein.
Dann sagt er. Ach ja sorry.
Ich hab meinen Post editiert.
Ich hab meinen Code jetzt richtig eingerückt.
Und dann drei Wochen keine Antwort.
Niemand kümmert sich mehr drum.
Aber Hauptsache mal gemeckert.
Also gerade bei advanceren Themen.
Ist.
In einem Forum um Hilfe fragen.
Oftmals.
Zeitverschwendung.
Ist einfach so.
Bei easy Sachen wo es noch genug Leute geben könnte.
Aber bei advanceren Themen ist wirklich.
In einem Forum fragen zu 99% Zeitverschwendung.
Was besser ist.
Anstatt in einem Forenbeitrag zu stecken.
Tatsächlich in erweitertes googeln zu stecken.
Weil man lernt ja mit der Zeit ein bisschen was.
Und kennt dann ein paar neue Begriffe.
Nach denen man suchen kann.
Also die Zeit ist meist deutlich besser investiert.
Suchmaschinen zu bedienen.
Anstelle von.
In einem Forums Post.
Wenn es advancer Themen sind.
Was auch gut ist.
Was auch gut funktioniert.
Sind Discord Channels.
Allerdings muss man die passenden Discord Channels dafür kennen.
Es gibt bestimmt Discord Channels.
Die sind so wie das Mikrocontroller Forum.
Aber es gibt auch Discord Channels.
Die sind sehr hilfreich.
Wenn es wirklich spezialisierte Themen sind.
Zum Beispiel.
Das kenne ich jetzt.
Reddit kann auch ganz gut sein.
Da ist es auch teilweise ähnlich.
Ähnlich wie in Foren.
Aber Discord Channels habe ich gemerkt.
Wenn es ein sehr spezielles Thema ist.
Und man hat einen sehr spezialisierten Channel.
Da sind die Leute enorm hilfbereit.
Weil.
Die das persönlich interessiert.
Dieses Thema.
Beispiel von der Arbeit.
Ich bin ja in einem Projekt.
Wo es unter anderem um.
Kryptowährungen geht.
Und wir benutzen dort eine Software.
Um beispielsweise.
Nodes für Polygon zu betreiben.
Kryptonodes für Polygon.
Und für diese Software.
Gibt es einen Discord Channel.
Da sind die Entwickler der Software drin.
Plus.
Da sind auch viele drin.
Die eigene Kryptonodes betreiben.
Mit dieser Software.
Die sind da.
Also wirklich extrem investiert.
In dieses Thema.
Und kennen sich aus.
Und sind auch super hilfsbereit.
Da hatten wir beispielsweise schon Probleme.
Mit Zugriffszeiten auf SSDs und sowas.
Und da haben Leute.
Freiwillig.
Weil es sich interessiert hat.
Mit uns.
Anpassungen.
Uns Config Anpassungen erklärt.
Weil die Docs der Software so kacke sind.
Und die haben sich richtig gefreut.
Als es funktioniert hat.
Also Discord Channels.
Wenn es Discord Channels gibt.
Für dieses eine Thema.
Und man weiß.
Das Problem was mit diesem Thema zu tun hat.
Dann sind Discord Channels oftmals sehr hilfreich.
Weil ich habe den Eindruck.
Das Chat ist noch etwas direkter.
Als ein Diskussionsforum.
Wenn Leute in einem Chat.
Explizit auf etwas antworten.
So nach dem Motto.
Probier doch mal das und das aus.
Dann ist das eine direktere Interaktion.
Als in so einem Diskussionsforum.
Und es ist auch.
Die Überwindung.
Ich lese mir das jetzt durch.
Ich schreibe da jetzt etwas drauf.
Ich weiß der Antwort muss dann zurück gestellt werden.
Da reagieren eher auch die Leute darauf.
Die von diesem Thema dann soweit Ahnung haben.
Das ihnen das schon etwas sagt.
Ich habe fast nur gute Erfahrungen gemacht.
Wenn es um Probleme mit.
Open Source Software.
Oder generell mit Technik Sachen geht.
Discord Channels sind wirklich.
Discord Server.
Sind wirklich nice für sowas.
Reddit kann auch nice sein.
Wenn es das passende Subreddit ist.
Es gibt aber auch Microcontroller Forum.
Like Subreddits.
Kennst du dich mit Krypto aus?
Das ist ein so breites Feld.
Das ich sagen muss.
Nein kenne ich mich nicht aus.
Als mit dem ich mich auskenne.
Ich kenne mich mit der Infrastruktur Seite.
Vom Betreiben.
Mancher Blockchain Nodes aus.
Da wollte ich jetzt nicht drauf klicken.
Aber okay.
Mit der Theorie dahinter.
Kenne ich mich.
Ein bisschen aus.
Bisschen.
So mit der History.
Mit Bitcoin hat es.
Hatte nicht wirklich mit Bitcoin angefangen.
Es hat ja mit verschiedenen theoretischen Dingen.
Mit Bitcoins ging es los.
Da gab es ein paar Bitcoin Forks.
Irgendwann gab es dann.
Ethereum.
Die das quasi neu entwickelt haben.
Nochmal eine eigene Cryptocurrency.
Die nicht auf Bitcoin basiert.
Ein bisschen.
Aber ich würde jetzt nicht sagen.
Das ich so wahnsinnig viel Ahnung davon habe.
Oh Kokona Musik Leute.
Hell yeah.
Das ist glaube ich aus dem Red Dead Redemption Soundtrack.
Okay genug Kokona.
So gut.
Das Thema alles dicht.
Ups falsche Richtung.
Ein bisschen Chat dicht gemacht.
So habe ich irgendwas übersehen.
Wie viele Forum Mitglieder braucht so eine Klübe?
Das ist eine typische Frage.
Da kannst du die Antwort nicht drauf kennen.
Erzähl es uns.
Das Heise Forum ist auch so ein Ding.
Hast du einen Tipp wie man Karriere machen kann ohne Führungsposition zu übernehmen?
Ja.
Ich habe einen ultimativen Tipp für dich.
Ahnung haben.
Tiefgreifend technisch Ahnung haben.
Anstatt Bullshit labern.
Am besten noch in einem Bereich der gesucht ist.
Aber Ahnung haben ist schon mal eine super Grundlage für Karriere machen.
Beziehungsweise ich weiß ja nicht was du unter Karriere machen verstehst.
Wenn du unter Karriere machen tatsächlich sowas hier verstehst ja dann nicht.
So den klassischen Karriere Management Grind.
Den wird es nur mit Führungspositionen oder zumindest mit Projektleitungspositionen geben.
Aber gute Unternehmen haben mittlerweile mehrere Karrieremöglichkeiten.
Also nicht nur.
Die klassische Karrieremöglichkeit von Führungskraft.
Also du wirst erst Gruppenleiter, Teamleiter, Abteilungsleiter whatever.
Das ist das eine.
Die haben dann meistens noch eine Projekt Karriere Bahn.
Du wirst Projektleiter.
Dann wirst du vielleicht irgendwie Leiter von dem und dem neuen was immer.
Also Richtung Projekt.
Und dann wenn die es gescheit machen gibt es noch so eine Art Technik Karriere.
Abbiegungsspur.
Wo du dann sowas machen kannst.
Wie beispielsweise du bist erstmal Hauptansprechpartner für ein spezielles Thema.
Du wirst vielleicht.
Du wirst vielleicht Architekt.
Bei einem Projekt.
Ohne das du eben Verantwortung für das Projekt hast.
Sowohl personell als auch irgendwie Budgetmäßig.
Sondern du bist da quasi der erste Ansprechpartner.
Wenn es um Architektur und Technik geht.
Dann wirst du vielleicht irgendwie mal.
Ja Hauptansprechpartner.
Sowas in der Richtung.
Oder du bist.
Experte in dem und dem Gebiet.
Bist dann beispielsweise.
Für gesamte.
Storage Infrastruktur.
Der Hauptansprechpartner und sowas in der Richtung.
Geht dann immer weiter.
Aber ganz ehrlich.
Die beste Art Karriere zu machen.
Aus meiner Sicht wenn es um Technik Sachen geht.
Ist Ahnung haben.
Ahnung haben und.
Da kommt der Knackpunkt.
Was bei vielen Leuten.
Das Problem ist.
Und ich will nicht sagen bei mir nicht.
Kann jeder an sich arbeiten was das angeht.
Nicht nur Ahnung haben.
Ahnung haben alleine bringt dir auch nichts.
Aber Ahnung haben ist meiner Meinung nach.
Voraussetzung das du.
Den Schritt schaffst von.
Ich bin einfach nur Schwätzer.
Zu es ist auch was dahinter.
Wenn man was sagt.
Also Ahnung haben ist meiner Meinung nach.
Enorm wichtig.
Es gibt viele Leute die haben keine Ahnung.
Und reden viel drüber.
Das bringt dir aber auch nichts.
Es gibt auch viele Leute die haben keine Ahnung.
Und versuchen möglichst viel zu machen.
Die machen möglichst viel kaputt.
Ahnung haben ist gut.
Dementsprechend mit der Ahnung was gescheites machen.
Und wenn man was gescheites gemacht hat.
Dann.
Das was man gemacht hat.
Breit treten bis zum geht nicht mehr.
Das muss mindestens mal dein Chef mitkriegen.
Was cooles gemacht hast.
Am besten kriegen das aber auch noch viel mehr mit.
Und wenn du dich dazu.
Aufraffen kannst.
Bei vielen Unternehmen gibt es ja die Möglichkeit.
Dort irgendeinen Vortrag mal drüber zu halten.
Also ich habe das.
Schon bei meinem Ausbildungsbetrieb gesehen.
Plus bei dem Laden wo ich danach war.
Plus bei dem Laden wo ich jetzt bin.
Es gibt da immer wieder so Veranstaltungen.
Wo unterschiedliche Teams und Abteilungen halt.
Coole Sachen vorstellen können.
Ja das finden natürlich.
Die jeweiligen Chefs auch gut.
Und guck mal was meine Abteilung.
Was mein Team.
Was meine Gruppe für geile Sachen macht.
Und das ist eine optimale Gelegenheit.
Die Dinger die man gemacht hat.
Irgendwie nochmal möglichst öffentlichkeitswirksam.
Zu verkaufen.
Und das ist sinnvoll.
Weil das möglichst viele mitkriegen.
Also wenn ihr die Auswahl habt.
Zu 100%
Technik zu machen.
Und geile Sachen und tolle Sachen zu machen.
Das kann ja keiner den ganzen Tag.
So viele tolle Sachen gibt es ja gar nicht zu machen.
Also mal angenommen man hat die Auswahl.
Zwischen 100%
Alles super bearbeiten.
Sich tolle neue Sachen auszudenken.
Oder.
50% tolle Sachen zu machen.
Und 50% da drüber zu labern.
Das man tolle Sachen gemacht hat.
Dann ist das für deine Karriere.
Auf jeden Fall die bessere Variante.
Und noch deutlich effizienter ist es.
Wenn man.
Anstatt sich wild.
Auf alles drauf zu stürzen.
Sich die Sachen rauspickt.
Die sich gut dafür eignen.
Ja also.
Zum Beispiel.
Ja.
Was nehmen wir denn jetzt mal.
Ja okay ich weiß was.
Zum Beispiel.
Ihr.
Baut irgendein Skript um.
Für irgendeine Linux Kiste.
Das die jetzt.
Wenn man sich drauf einloggt.
Keine Ahnung.
Mir fällt einfach dafür gerade kein gescheites Beispiel ein.
Ja also.
Worauf ich raus will ist.
Mal angenommen ihr baut was.
Was technisch sehr cool ist.
Aber.
Außerhalb von euch.
Und eurem Team.
Kein groß betrifft.
Beziehungsweise kein groß interessiert.
Dann ist das eine coole Sache.
War bestimmt auch nicht einfach.
Aber ist schwierig großartig zu verkaufen.
Also wenn es schon schwierig ist.
Eurem Chef zu erklären.
Zum Beispiel.
Wenn ihr seht okay.
Es gibt hier.
Machen wir mal ein Beispiel.
Beispiel von dem letzten Laden wo ich gearbeitet habe.
Ein Beispiel.
Es gab dort.
Einen Anbieter.
Der Spam E-Mails gefiltert hat.
Und.
Was man dazu wissen muss.
Wir hatten Außendienst Mitarbeiter.
Die E-Mails geschickt haben.
Über unser System.
Beim alten Arbeitgeber wo ich war.
Haben auch ab und zu mal.
Spam verschickt.
Das lag unter anderem daran.
Weil die sich vielleicht auf ihrem privaten Laptop.
Irgendein Virus eingefangen hatten.
Oder manche haben auch wirklich.
Einfach an 5000 Leute.
Eine Geburtstags Mail geschickt.
Zumindest.
Wenn das dann an 5000 Adressen geht.
Mit dem gleichen Ding.
Dann ist das halt auch was was.
Andere E-Mail Anbieter.
Gmx, Gmail und so.
Das ist ja nicht so einfach.
Wir hatten einen Spam Filter Anbieter.
Der quasi.
Klingt jetzt blöd.
Aber es war der richtige Weg.
Der ausgehende E-Mails.
Filtert auf Spam.
Also sprich.
Nicht E-Mails die wir bekommen.
Sondern E-Mails die wir verschicken.
Hat er auf Spam überprüft.
Sodass wir im Zweifelsfall.
Nicht auf irgendeiner Blacklist landen.
Versteht man was ich meine?
Zumindest gab es dort.
Manchmal halt auch ein paar.
So so so.
False positives.
E-Mails die im Spam hingen.
Aber eigentlich gar nicht im Spam hängen sollten.
Und das hat man daran erkannt.
Weil das von speziellen E-Mail Adressen.
Gekommen ist.
Das waren spezielle E-Mail Adressen.
Da wusste man okay.
Wenn von diesen E-Mail Adressen was kommt.
Auch wenn das eventuell in dem Spam Filter auffällt.
Ist das was was wir auf jeden Fall verschicken wollen.
So.
Das ist ein Workflow.
Der da hieß.
Unsere Support Leute.
Müssen sich mehrfach am Tag.
In das Web Interface einloggen.
Dort nach speziellen E-Mail Adressen suchen.
Nach speziellen Domains suchen.
Und jeder einzelne dieser Dinger.
Das war dann in Kombination.
Irgendwie 14 verschiedene Dinger.
Die man aufmachen musste.
In diesen 14 verschiedenen Dingern.
Runterscrollen.
Gucken ob E-Mails drin sind.
Die E-Mails.
Also alle E-Mails markieren.
Oder freigeben klicken.
Oder aus Quarantäne entfernen.
Oder wie das hieß klicken.
Und dann war gut.
Das musste ich mehrfach am Tag machen.
Für 14 verschiedene Sachen.
Und das war teuer.
Fehleranfällig.
Und hat alle abgefuckt.
Und irgendwann bin ich dann mal hingegangen.
Und hab gesagt wisst ihr was.
Das kann man doch garantiert.
Irgendwie automatisch machen.
Dann haben wir bei dem Anbieter angefragt.
Ob die nicht irgendwie eine API haben.
Für ihre Anti Spam Schnittstelle.
Und da habe ich die beste Antwort.
Überhaupt gehört.
Von so einem Sales Typ.
Bei denen.
Oder von irgendeinem Marketing Typ.
Der hat gesagt.
Oh ja.
Das ist eine tolle Anfrage.
Und das haben sie sich auch schon überlegt.
Und sie sind da super.
Ja was auch immer.
Und sie haben schon.
Einen internen Feature Request offen.
Der dieses Thema behandelt.
Was im Prinzip heißt.
Wir haben nix.
Das war verklausuliert die Antwort.
Aber war schon.
Gute Antwort.
Also sie haben im Endeffekt gesagt.
Wir haben keine API die ihr direkt ansprechen könntet.
Die ihr direkt ansprechen könnt.
Aber wir haben es intern.
Schon mal vor 2-3 Jahren aufgenommen.
Und noch nix gemacht.
Hat er super schön verkauft.
So und was hab ich dann gemacht.
Ich hab mich hingesetzt.
Hab mir das ganze mal angeguckt.
Was die machen.
Und ich hab dann mit Puppeteer.
Heute würde man wahrscheinlich nicht mehr Puppeteer.
Sondern.
Oh wie heißt das jetzt.
Versus Moment.
Playwright würde man wahrscheinlich heute verwenden.
Selenium war oldschool.
Danach kam Puppeteer.
Heute.
Hat einen ähnlichen Namen.
Heute wird man wahrscheinlich Playwright nehmen.
Ich hab dann Puppeteer genommen.
Das ist ein Chrome.
Chrome Automatisierungs.
Framework.
Damit kann man.
Chrome fernsteuern.
Und das ganze ohne grafische Ausgaben.
Man kann quasi einen Headless Chrome starten.
Und.
Dann mit Puppeteer Chrome sagen.
Was der für einen klicken soll.
Heißt im Endeffekt.
Man kann quasi das.
Was die Leute von Hand geklickt haben.
In diesem Web Interface nachgebaut.
Mit einem Chrome.
Der ferngesteuert wird von einem Skript.
Im Endeffekt so.
Das ganze habe ich in ein .NET Executable gepackt.
Haben wir auf eine Kiste geschoben.
Und das läuft da.
Und das läuft glaube ich jetzt jahrelang schon.
Ich denke mal das läuft jetzt.
Ich bin jetzt seit über einem Jahr dort schon weg.
Ich denke mal das läuft.
Das geht mit Selenium geht das auch.
Ich denke mal das läuft immer noch.
Im Prinzip ist das auch relativ easy gewesen.
Du machst dann halt so Dinge wie.
Suche den Login Button.
Klicke drauf.
Mache das und das.
Es war ein bisschen kompliziert.
Weil die Seite zwei Faktor Authentifizierung verwendet hat.
Ich habe dann quasi noch zwei Faktor Authentifizierung.
In dieses Skript eingebaut.
Das es auch zwei Faktor Authentifizierung machen kann.
Aus einem Faktor.
Also das konnte sich zwei Faktor Authentifizierung.
Per zwei Faktor Authentifizierung anmelden.
Ohne wirklich.
Einen zweitenen Faktor zu benötigen.
Weil ich so getan habe.
Als wäre mein Skript die Authentifizierungs App.
Die normalerweise auf dem Handy läuft.
So und das ist so ein Ding.
Das ist Big Brain.
Aus technischer Sicht gewesen.
Wenn es auch für euch.
Ich weiß wir haben hier richtig krasse Hackermans im Stream.
Für euch natürlich.
Für viele von euch eine easy Sache ist.
Ein bisschen Browser Automatisierung zu bauen.
Und ich will jetzt nicht sagen das es super schwierig war.
Aber das ist ein Thema.
Was für Außenstehende super.
Also super High IQ.
Wenn du sowas automatisierst.
Aber es ist auch ein Thema.
Was man sehr gut verkaufen kann.
Weil man kann dann sagen.
Hey guck mal.
Vorher hatten wir den Workflow.
Wo du 24 7 Support Leute benötigt hast.
Drei verschiedene Schichten am Tag.
14 verschiedene Seiten.
Und was da alles dran gehangen hat.
Und jetzt passiert das automatisiert.
Ohne dass sich irgendjemand drum kümmern muss.
Kann sagen guck mal Leute.
Was das für Geld spart.
Was für Ressourcen spart.
Wie viel weniger fehleranfällig das Ganze ist.
Und das ist halt so ein Ding gewesen.
Solche Dinger kann man extrem gut verkaufen.
Versus.
Ihr habt irgendwas.
Bei euch.
Auf den Linux System angepasst.
Also es gibt manche Sachen.
Die haben einfach.
Mehr.
Die sind Prestigeträchtiger.
Weil man die besser verkaufen kann.
Auch an Leute die technisch wenig Ahnung haben.
Und das sind so die zwei Sachen.
Man kann erstens coole Sachen machen.
Sich coole Sachen raussuchen.
Von denen man weiß.
Wenn man den krassen Karriere-Crime machen will.
Dass sie.
Das Potential haben.
Prestigeträchtig zu sein.
Ja.
Aber Ahnung haben muss man trotzdem noch.
Das ist halt das was ich immer sage.
Man muss sich schon von den ganzen Schwätzern unterscheiden.
Die einfach nur labern den ganzen Tag.
Und vielleicht auch viel machen und viel kaputt machen.
Man muss technisch in der Lage sein.
Wie gesagt.
Ich will mich nicht super loben.
Das ist nicht sonderlich schwierig.
Weil ich gebaut habe.
Aber sowas rauszusuchen.
Das technisch umzusetzen.
Man muss die Ahnung haben das technisch umzusetzen.
Und dann muss man die andere Hälfte der Zeit dafür benutzen.
Das breit zu treten.
Breit zu treten.
Wenn man wirklich hier drauf Wert legt.
Das breit zu treten bis zum geht nicht mehr.
Euer Chef muss es mindestens mitkriegen.
Und euer Chef muss es nicht nur mitkriegen.
Er muss es verstanden haben.
So dass er das weitererzählen kann.
Und wenn du die Möglichkeit hast das dann noch vorzustellen.
Auf irgendeiner bisschen größeren Runde.
Dann ist das das Beste was du machen kannst.
Für deine Karriere.
Und ernsthaft.
Ich bin der Meinung man kann heutzutage.
Auch Karriere machen.
Wenn die Firma gescheit ist.
Ganz ohne Führungsposition oder Projektverantwortung.
Oder sonst was.
Und es ist unterm Strich besser sogar.
Für euch und für die jeweilige Firma.
Weil kaum gute Techniker.
Sind gute Manager.
Und kaum gute Manager sind gute Techniker.
Deswegen ist es eigentlich blöde.
Die Leute.
Eher auf diesen Projekt und Führungskarrieren.
Weg zu zwingen.
Wenn sie was machen müssen.
Auf das sie keinen Bock haben.
Und auch noch schlechter sind da drin.
Als in dem was sie ursprünglich gemacht haben.
Deswegen tun Unternehmen gut dran.
Auch wenn es in vielen nicht klappt.
Aber in vielen klappt es mittlerweile.
Wenn sie sich technisch weiterentwickeln wollen.
Die Möglichkeit zu bieten.
Man muss es aber auch nutzen.
Und das beste was man machen kann ist.
Wenn man was ordentliches gemacht hat.
Das breit treten.
Auch wenn es sich negativ anhört.
Breit treten bis zum geht nicht mehr.
Bis ihr merkt die Leute können es nicht mehr hören.
So wie die Story hier.
Die ich jetzt schon 10 mal erzählt habe.
Aber so muss man es machen.
Hat dir meine Antwort geholfen?
Falls du noch da bist.
Oh weiss ich.
Müsste ich mir Gedanken drüber machen.
Das ist für mich eher BWL Leute.
Ist Made Me Suffer noch da?
Er ist schon weg.
Ja geil.
Jetzt habe ich eine halbe Stunde gefühlt seine Frage im Antworten.
Er ist nicht mal mehr da.
Aber er ist öfters da.
Er ist öfters da.
Er hat schon 246 Nachrichten geschrieben.
Also wenn wir ihn mal wieder sehen.
Moment.
Post Champ.
Ich habe jetzt hier nichts übersehen.
Er geht auch.
Er ist so.
Bis zu einem gewissen Grad muss man den Kram mitspielen.
Und manchmal cringe man selbst ein bisschen.
Wenn man einfache Technik Sachen
so super
breit tritt.
Und als nice verkauft.
Aber so rum ist besser als anders rum.
Ach gibt übrigens noch ein Tipp.
Falls ihr regelmäßig
Rücksprachen habt.
Mit eurem Chef.
Abteilungsleiter oder whatever.
Was es da gibt bei euch.
Gibt ja manchmal so Feedback Gespräche.
Oder ja wie läuft es denn gerade.
Also gescheite Führungskräfte machen sowas
ab und zu mal.
Ja weil es ja durchaus auch mal Dinger gibt.
Die man nicht auf einer Teamrunde ansprechen will.
Oder vielleicht auch.
Immer nervt und so.
Ja am besten ist natürlich man geht direkt zu seinem Chef.
Wenn einem was nervt.
Sagt ey guck mal der sich letztens wieder angestellt hat man.
Von dem Projekt.
Ist ja auch sinnvoll.
Einfach da mal zusammensetzen.
Also ein Tipp den ich euch noch geben kann ist.
Und das mache ich auch schon eine Weile.
Weil das ja immer nur aus meiner Sicht berichten.
Ein Tipp den ich euch noch geben kann ist.
Schreibt euch ein paar Sachen auf.
Weil wenn wieder Gespräch mit eurem Chef ansteht.
Dann fallen euch die wichtigen Sachen.
So spontan gar nicht ein.
Es sei denn es steht halt gerade eine größere Sache an.
Wenn es was gibt.
Schreibt euch das einfach kurz auf.
Macht euch ein Text Dokument.
Und schreibt euch das mal auf.
Ihr werdet feststellen.
Wenn das so einmal im Monat ist zum Beispiel.
Oder einmal im Quartal.
Oder wie auch immer das bei euch ist.
Da sammeln sich die ein oder anderen Sachen an.
Erstens ist euer Chef happy.
Wenn ihr was habt.
Für solche Gespräche.
Da muss man sich aber nicht was aus dem Finger sorgen.
Ja.
Und es bietet tatsächlich die Chance.
Sich zu ein paar Themen.
Die einem am Herz liegen.
Weil.
Auch wenn man die vielleicht nicht mehr wüsste.
Wenn man sich nicht aufgeschaut hat.
Tatsächlich mal was dazu los zu werden.
Und es macht bei eurem Chef einen guten Eindruck.
Weil der sich denkt.
Ey guck mal.
Der hat ja jedes mal was.
Und der ist ja da voll engaged.
Und voll dabei.
Aber es bietet natürlich auch die Chance.
Ein paar Sachen anzusprechen.
Die euch auf den Keks gehen.
Oder eben Sachen breit zu treten.
Die ihr cooles gemacht habt.
Wenn es euch Spaß gemacht hat.
Da muss man sich selbst darauf einstellen.
Nicht das Gute.
Nicht das Beste.
Nicht das Wichtigste.
Und nicht dass ihr euch nicht richtig interessiert.
Für eine Person, die sich für Technik interessiert.
Für Leute die sich für Technik wirklich nicht interessieren.
Mit denen habe ich ungern.
Fachlich zu tun auf der Arbeit.
Ansonsten es darf sich jeder für das interessieren.
Was er möchte.
Wenn man sich allerdings im technischen Bereich bewegt.
Wenn man eine Position hat, wo man keine Ahnung haben muss, ist das vollkommen in Ordnung.
Ich erwarte nicht, dass jeder Ahnung hat.
Ich habe auch von vielmehr keine Ahnung, als dass ich Ahnung habe.
Also was schreibt ihr denn hier?
Ich litt unter dem in meinem Team, äh in einem Team von Application Manager, wo wir auch solche Personen eingestellt haben.
Alles liebe Leute, aber technikbezogen fragen sie entweder andere im Team oder gehen schnell auf das Date.
Für die sie nicht wirklich fahren möchten.
Ja, das ist das, was ich vorhin meinte mit.
Also Leute, die motiviert sind, aber keine Ahnung haben.
Das ist eine scheiß Kombination, weil die sind sehr motiviert, die machen viel, machen aber auch viel kaputt und viel Chaos und viel Kacke.
Da halte ich nichts von.
Also wer in einem technischen Bereich eingesetzt wird, als in der Position, wo es darum geht, sich auch damit auseinanderzusetzen,
haben Leute, die keine Ahnung haben, nichts verloren.
Was willst du damit anfangen?
Ich sage nicht, dass jeder alles wissen muss.
Aber jemand, der beispielsweise als...
Sagen wir mal, als Admin im Linux-Bereich anfängt oder als Java-Software-Entwickler, der aber außer Ubuntu in der VM daheim installiert, nichts mit Linux zu tun hat, der hat da nichts zu suchen.
Der hat da nichts zu suchen.
Es sei denn, es sei denn, und das will ich, ich will jetzt nicht alle Leute schlechtreden.
Es sei denn, es ist explizit so eine Einstiegs-, wir müssen es lernen Stelle.
Ja, also wenn jemand sich als Linux-Admin bewirbt, auf jeden Fall Einsteiger.
Und da richtig Bock drauf hat und sich dafür interessiert und sich da vielleicht auch ein bisschen schon Sachen angeguckt hat und es eine Stelle ist, wo eben geplant ist,
okay, den müssen wir jetzt erstmal ein, zwei Jahre einarbeiten, bis er richtig Plan hat.
Vollkommen okay.
Aber wenn es eine normale Stelle ist, wo es darum geht, dass man eben Ahnung von dem Thema hat und dann mogelt sich irgendjemand da rein mit,
weil er eher überzeugt hat im Vorstellungsgespräch, die auch keine Ahnung haben.
Deswegen ist es immer gut, wenn da auch...
Wenn da der Chef dabei ist und wenn der keine Ahnung hat, vielleicht auch jemand vom Team, der Plan hat, dann hat er da nichts zu suchen.
Dann macht er viel und macht viel Mist und macht viel kaputt, um das sich andere kümmern müssen.
Ich glaube, so gut wie jeder hat Probleme mit Ressourcen bzw. Mitarbeiter zu finden, die Ahnung haben.
Ich glaube, im Junior-Bereich ist es tatsächlich ein bisschen entspannter.
Da findet man doch noch ein bisschen mehr Leute.
Aber die suchen ja hauptsächlich Leute, die sich ein bisschen auskennen seit ein paar Jahren mit Thema X.
Und das ist schwierig, jemanden zu finden.
Durch die Bank weg zurzeit.
Meiner Meinung nach braucht es in der IT für die Position eines Application Managers.
Was?
Der Satz ergibt keinen Sinn.
Du meinst, es braucht jemanden mit Ahnung in der Position eines Application Managers?
Dazu kann ich nicht sagen, weil ich nicht weiß, was Application Manager bei euch machen.
Letztendlich ist das ja alles immer ein bisschen schwammig, was wie wo jemand macht.
Kommt auf das Aufgabenfeld an.
Ja, dann ist es...
Dann ist er eindeutig in der Position, wo er es wissen sollte, aber nicht weiß.
Das ist...
Das ist nicht schlimm.
Du kannst nicht alles wissen.
Wenn es aber jemand ist, der quasi die ganze Zeit so tut, wenn du den fragst, ja, okay, du musst die Kiste jetzt anlegen.
Weißt du, wie das geht?
Er sagt, ja, ja.
Und du ihm dann sagen willst, ja, und bei uns ist es so, wir haben so ein extra Tool für DNS-Verwaltung.
Und er sagt dann, ja, ja, passt schon, ich weiß, wie das geht.
Tu nicht so, als wäre ich blöd.
So, Leute, da habe ich immer ein bisschen...
Meine Bedenken, weil da hat sich oft genug rausgestellt, dass die, ja, nicht wollen, dass man sie expost.
Die angenehmsten Leute sind die, die zugeben können, wenn sie von was keine Ahnung haben.
Das sind auch meistens die Leute, die richtig viel Plan haben.
Also, zumindest ist das so eine Tendenz, die ich festgestellt habe.
Leute, die ohne Probleme zugeben können, dass sie von etwas Konkretem keine Ahnung haben, sind meistens die, die am meisten Ahnung haben.
So allgemein betrachtet, ja.
Also, wenn die sagen, ey, ich habe keine Ahnung von, wie ihr das in Ansible macht, dann finde ich das vollkommen gerechtfertigt,
weil es kann niemand im Vorfeld wissen, wie irgendwas in Ansible irgendjemand mal vor fünf Jahren gebaut hat.
Aber wenn das einer ist, der das so offen zugibt, da kannst du davon ausgehen, der hat Ansible schon mal benutzt und hat eigentlich relativ viel Plan davon.
Und dem zeigst du das zweimal und dann geht's.
Wohingegen jemand, der sagt, easy, ich mache Ansible schon seit drei Jahren.
Du musst mir gar nichts erzählen.
Das sind eher die Leute, wo ich mir denke, das sind eher nicht die, denen ich so viel Vertrauen entgegenbringe.
Bestes Beispiel ist auch unser Storage-Typ, den wir mal hatten.
Der am ersten Tag irgendwelche Storage, wie nennt sich das bei Storage?
Storage, nicht VLANs?
So Storage-VLANs, wie nennt man das denn?
Gibt's auch so spezielles Wort für Storage?
Irgendso ein Cisco-Ding.
Wie heißt denn der Krempel?
San?
Zonen?
Nee.
Loon?
Nein.
Gibt es nicht so Cisco?
Gibt es nicht sowas wie San-VLANs oder sowas?
Sowas ähnliches, ja.
Zumindest sowas ähnliches wie Zonen vielleicht.
Ich hab von Storage keine Ahnung.
Das ist auch so ein Ding.
Ich hab überhaupt keine Probleme zu sagen, ich habe von Storage keine Ahnung.
Und auch was SQL-Sachen angeht, hab ich nicht so sonderlich viel Plan.
Ich finde das überhaupt kein Ding zuzugeben, wenn man voraus keine Ahnung hat.
Der hat am ersten Tag, das war auch so ein Ding.
Das war auch so jemand, der hat immer gesagt, wobei es war nicht am ersten Tag, es war glaube ich am zweiten Tag, wo er da war.
Zweiten Tag, da habe ich auch ein Video dazu gemacht.
Das war auch so jemand, der hat immer gesagt, du musst mir nichts zeigen, ich mache Storage schon seit fünf Jahren und sowas in der Richtung.
Ich weiß das alles und ja, ja, klar, logisch, ich mache das.
Der Kerl hat an seinem ersten oder zweiten Tag, wo er da war, irgendwelche komischen Dinger, wie San meine ich, V-San, jetzt weiß ich es wieder, heißt der Kram.
Storage.
Storage, V-San.
Ja, genau.
Der hat irgendwelche, ich weiß bis heute nicht genau, was es ist, ehrlich gesagt, aber als Storage-Experte solltest du es wissen.
Der hat am ersten Tag oder am zweiten Tag irgendwelche V-Sans angelegt, deployed in Produktion, hat festgestellt, fuck, ich habe irgendwas verkackt und ist dann abgehauen.
Der ist wirklich abgehauen.
Der war dann fünf, sechs Stunden weg in der Mittagspause, weil er wusste, es ist in die Hose gegangen.
Der ist einfach abgehauen.
Und als er dann wiedergekommen ist und die Sachen mittlerweile wieder funktioniert haben, muss er sein Notebook abgeben und die Security hat ihn rausgebracht und er durfte das Gebäude nie wieder betreten.
Da habe ich ja ein Video zu gemacht, ja.
Das war die Kurzfassung von.
Und bei so Leuten habe ich immer Bedenken.
Bei so Leuten.
Wenn jemand zu mir sagt, Max, keine Ahnung, das und das, die und die Konfig, da habe ich noch nie reingeguckt, keine Ahnung.
Da kannst du relativ sicher von ausgehen.
Die haben eigentlich Plan, die Leute.
Die haben nämlich kein Problem damit, was zuzugeben, wenn sie diese eine spezielle Sache nicht kennen.
Und ich sage es mittlerweile auch relativ zeitig, wenn ich feststelle, ey, zum Beispiel Check-MK ist so ein Ding.
Bei mir, jetzt wo ich angefangen habe, haben wir Check-MK und ich habe im Vorfeld nie großartig was mit Check-MK gemacht.
Ich kenne mich ganz gut aus im Bereich Monitoring, ja.
Ich habe schon, wie gesagt, ich sage ja immer, ich habe ein weiches Herz für Nachrichten.
Ich habe mich mit Nagios, weil das quasi so mein erstes richtiges Projekt noch in der Ausbildung gewesen ist, ja.
Ich habe mich mit Nagios viel beschäftigt, mit Zabbix, mit Prometheus, mit Visualisierung, Grafana, mit Alerting, mit Alertmanager, mit irgendwelchen Dashboards bauen.
Alles mögliche, aber von Check-MK selbst habe ich keine Ahnung.
Und ich sage das auch immer, wenn es ums Thema Check-MK geht, sage ich mir, ey Leute, das ist für mich keine Ahnung.
Und dazu kommt, ich mag Check-MK nicht.
Ja, manchmal muss man sich mit Sachen beschäftigen, die man nicht mag.
Aber Check-MK ist so ein Ding.
Also, ich mag das Webinterface nicht.
Du merkst dem an, dass die einfach 15 Jahre lang keinen Webdesigner im Team hatten.
Was ich mir nicht ausdenke, was ich mir nicht ausdenke, sondern was man sieht, auch bei denen im Forum.
Die haben erst seit einem halben Jahr oder so einen Webdesigner, der in diesem Check-MK-Forum rumspukt.
Und du merkst diesem Interface an, die hatten 15 Jahre keinen Webdesigner.
Check-MK hat, glaube ich, somit das schlechteste Webinterface von allen Monitoring-Tools, die ich kenne, die ein Webinterface haben.
Das hatte fast ein schlechteres Webinterface als Nagios.
Wobei Check-MK ursprünglich, glaube ich, sogar von Nagios abstammt.
Also, das ist wirklich ein so grausam verfrickeltes Webinterface wie Check-MK, habe ich bei Monitoring-Tools noch nicht gesehen.
Und ich sage davon auch, ich habe keine Ahnung.
Und ich will davon auch keine Ahnung haben.
Ich mache da drin, was nötig ist und gut ist.
Check-MK ist so ein Ding, ich mag es einfach nicht.
Ja.
Sobald es dort um irgendwelche advancede Dinger geht.
Wie irgendwelche Wildcard-Notification-Blacklists und sowas.
Sag ich auch mal, Leute, ich mache das, aber Bock habe ich nicht drauf.
Hast du den Reddit-Zug?
Nee.
Das habe ich gelesen.
Doch, das habe ich gelesen.
Ja, ja.
Das ist irgendein kleiner Laden, der tausende Euro an Beratern bezahlt.
Das sind Nagios für den Sub.
Lohnt es sich, eine IT-Umschulung, auch wenn man nicht gut programmieren kann?
Also, ich übertrage das jetzt mal auf eine Ausbildung.
Eine Ausbildung macht auch Sinn, wenn man Spaß daran hat, an Anwendungsentwicklung,
ohne dass man richtig gut programmieren kann, weil eine Ausbildung ist dafür da, es zu lernen.
Wenn du was noch nicht gut kannst, ist nicht das Problem.
Die Frage ist, ob du Interesse daran hast, es zu lernen.
Wenn du kein Interesse generell am Gebiet Softwareentwicklung hast,
ist vielleicht eine Umschulung auf Anwendungsentwickler nicht so deins.
Kommt darauf an, was du für eine Umschulung machen willst.
Also, das Gebiet muss dich schon interessieren.
Sonst ist es ja quasi, quälst du dich da ja nur durch.
Und die besten Leute in der IT sind tatsächlich welche, die sich dafür interessieren und das auch privat.
Ja, das habe ich schon oft genug festgestellt.
Also, es muss nicht so der klassische, ich sitze im dunklen Keller Dude sein, wie ich, ja.
Wobei, das ist ja mittlerweile gar nicht mehr stimmt.
Ich habe es euch ja letztens im Stream gezeigt, ich habe tatsächlich eine gewisse Bräune auf meinen Ärmen.
Dort, wo ich keine...
Uhr und Handschuhe habe.
Das ist ganz ungewohnt für mich.
Ja.
Aber man muss es ja nicht so wie ich machen, 15 Jahre fast nur im Keller sitzen und...
Ohne viel Interaktion mit der Außenwelt, um gut zu werden, was IT-Themen angeht.
Wobei ich mir halt das Gebiet ausgesucht habe, weil ich da gerade nicht mit so vielen Leuten interagieren muss.
Ja, das muss man ja nicht machen.
Aber ich habe gemerkt, dass Leute, die sich gut technisch auskennen, oftmals auch Leute sind,
die sich eben auch privat für dieses Thema interessieren.
Also, nichts dagegen zu sagen, wenn man, ja, im Prinzip nur seinen Job macht, gar kein Problem.
Bin ich der Letzte, der das irgendwie schlecht findet?
Man sollte das machen, was man angemessen hält für die Kohle, die man bekommt.
Aber die besten Leute, die ich kenne, die sind durch und durch Technik interessiert, ja.
Also, das sind dann welche, die programmieren auch mal Microcontroller in ihrer Freizeit, weil sie es interessiert, ja.
Und basteln an irgendwelchen Technik-Sachen.
Weil sie es interessiert.
Die beschäftigen sich mit Heimautomatisierung, weil sie eben Technik-Zeug interessiert.
Ja, die beschäftigen sich mit neuen Entwicklungen, was irgendwelche Linux-Tools angeht, ohne dass es direkt in Bezug zu arbeiten, weil sie es interessiert.
Also, die besten Leute, die ich kenne, die sind so durch und durch IT interessiert, auch privat.
Von nix kommt nix, ja.
Natürlich muss man Prioritäten setzen, das habe ich auch jetzt mittlerweile schon gemerkt.
Die Zeiten, dass ich tatsächlich...
aufgestanden bin,
an den Rechner gegangen bin,
gearbeitet habe am Rechner,
danach weiter am Rechner komplett hocken geblieben bin,
sind nicht vorbei.
Das ist immer noch so.
Aber ich habe gemerkt, dass reines 24-7 am Rechner hocken gesundheitlich nicht so gut ist.
Und seitdem ich angefangen habe, mich regelmäßig zu bewegen, zu rennen und zu Fahrrad fahren,
auch wenn es nur einen kleinen Teil der Zeit ist,
einen kleinen Teil meines Tages in Anspruch nimmt,
geht es mir insgesamt deutlich besser als vorher.
Also 24-7 am Rechner sitzen ist auch nicht die Lösung.
16 Stunden am Rechner sitzen reicht.
Oder sagen wir mal 12, 13, 14 Stunden am Rechner sitzen reicht.
Also ich mache das, bei mir sieht das ohne Scheiß...
Also mein Tag, mein Tag sieht, wenn ich Homeoffice habe,
restliche Kram ist Bahn, sinnloses Hin- und Zurückfahren,
mein Homeoffice-Tag sieht folgendermaßen aus.
Ich stehe so 7.30 Uhr auf in dem Dreh, setze mich an den Computer,
mache ein bisschen Zeug auf hier, ein bisschen Musik-Kram im Hintergrund,
zweiten Rechner an, mache ein bisschen YouTube an, dass ein bisschen Beschallung läuft,
logge mich ein, Remote auf der Arbeit,
dann mache ich Homeoffice auf der Arbeit bis, sagen wir mal so 15.30 Uhr, 16 Uhr.
So, normal bin ich jetzt, also ja gut, zwischendurch gehe ich mal kurz was essen und sowas.
Ja, normal bin ich danach einfach weiter am Rechner hocken geblieben.
Bis 22 Uhr, dann bin ich pennen gegangen und das danach wieder.
Mittlerweile ist es so, dass ich, wenn ich fertig bin mit der Arbeit,
eineinhalb Stunden mal eine Runde durch die Landschaft laufe,
ja, drumherum, nicht rennen, nicht Fahrrad fahren, nicht joggen,
sondern wirklich einfach nur nochmal nach dem Tag eineinhalb Stunden draußen
mal ein bisschen an der frischen Luft rumlaufen.
Ich gehe meistens morgens so um halb neun,
halb neun in dem Dreh gehe ich mal eine Runde rennen.
Das ist zwischen, je nachdem was der Plan vorsieht,
ist das zwischen 35 Minuten bis eine Stunde zehn.
So, je nachdem was da angesagt ist.
Ich habe hier so einen generierten Trainingsplan, wo dann drinnen steht,
heute muss ich übrigens mal gucken, heute war ich noch nicht.
Heute sagt er zum Beispiel 40 Minuten Base Ausdauer,
jetzt muss ich langsam sieben Minuten pro Kilometer erholsam joggen,
ist heute angesagt, muss ich nachher noch machen, wenn es nicht pisst.
Ja, das mache ich vormittags und mittags gehe ich entweder eine Runde Fahrrad fahren,
anstelle der Runde laufen, also anstelle der Runde spazieren gehen
oder ich kombiniere das irgendwie so, dass ich sage,
hey, ich gehe jetzt eineinhalb, zwei, drei Stunden Fahrrad fahren.
Also drei Stunden Fahrrad fahren mache ich unter der Woche selten.
Also ich mache meistens so zwei Stunden Fahrrad fahren,
wenn es ein bisschen größere Runde ist, zwei Stunden Fahrrad fahren mittags
und dann gehe ich vielleicht noch mal kurz hier bis ein bisschen durchs Ort,
vielleicht irgendwas einkaufen, noch mal so 40 Minuten.
Also ich bin ungefähr nach dem Homeoffice so zwei bis drei Stunden beschäftigt
mit irgendwas anderem und dann sitze ich den restlichen Tag am Rechner.
Also ich sage mal so, ich höre 14.30 Uhr auf und bin so 16.30 Uhr, 17.00 Uhr, 17.00 Uhr,
17.30 Uhr, je nachdem, bin ich wieder am Rechner
und dann hocke ich halt noch mal sechs Stunden am Rechner.
Fünf bis sechs Stunden am Rechner.
Ich penne und dann wieder das Gleiche.
So, das ist nicht so viel Unterschied zu früher,
aber es ist wohlfühltechnisch ein Riesenunterschied zu früher.
Früher war ich außer Puste, wenn ich über die Schranke rennen musste,
weil ich gesehen habe, die geht zu.
Heute kann ich eineinhalb Stunden am Stück,
eineinhalb Stunden am Stück rennen,
zwölf, dreizehn Kilometer
und danach denke ich mir so,
ja, nice Strecke gewesen, alles gut,
bisschen was trinken, bisschen was futtern und vor den Rechner hocken.
Da bin ich nicht, früher wäre ich,
früher hättest du mich in den Sarg stecken können, deadge,
wenn ich eineinhalb Stunden hätte rennen müssen.
Da hätte ich nicht geschafft, ich wäre gestorben unterwegs,
das ist keine Übertreibung.
Ich wäre, hätte früher jemand gesagt,
du musst eineinhalb Stunden am Stück rennen, joggen, rennen.
Ich weiß nicht, ist, ist, ist,
knapp sechs, sechs Minuten pro Kilometer,
ist das schon rennen oder noch joggen?
Ich würde sagen, das ist so gerade die Grenze, ja.
Das ist das, was ich schaffe über zwölf, dreizehn Kilometer.
Wenn ich, wenn ich, dann bin ich ziemlich kaputt danach,
aber alles noch gut, ja, so, so sechs, sechszehn irgendwie pro Kilometer,
sechs Minuten pro Kilometer, so zwölf, dreizehn Kilometer lang.
Ich bleibe, bin ich, Relations zuiminiert.
Ich erneut nicht so, dass ich heutzutage und
ich mich, alle Dinge in meinem Leben slope,
aber ohne ich, dasieu, ich erneut
und erneut entsprechendiqué für
dafür.
hätte früher jemand zu mir gesagt, Max,
du musst jetzt eineinhalb Stunden am Stück
rennen. Ich hätte gesagt, das geht nicht. Wieso? Wie soll ich das machen?
Und
dann hätte jemand irgendwie, keine Ahnung,
einen Dinosaurier hinter mir herhetzen
müssen oder einen Hund oder was auch immer, dass ich hätte
eineinhalb Stunden rennen können. Und ich wäre, ohne Scheiß,
ich wäre wahrscheinlich verreckt früher.
Aber eineinhalb Stunden,
wäre einfach abgekratzt. Mittlerweile
geht das ganz gut. Also der Unterschied,
worauf ich raus will, ist der Unterschied zwischen
acht Stunden
vorm PC hängen und dann nochmal acht Stunden vorm PC
hängen und dann pengen gehen und wieder acht Stunden vorm PC hängen
versus acht Stunden vorm PC hängen,
zwei bis drei Stunden sich ein bisschen
anderweitig betätigen
und dann wieder nur sechs Stunden vorm PC
hängen, ist wohlfühltechnisch
ein riesen Unterschied.
Sechs Minuten pro Kilometer ist dann mit
G-Pausen, nee, nicht mit G-Pausen. Ich kann das
durchrennen mittlerweile. Also das
schnellste, was ich geschafft habe, ist,
also über fünf Kilometer, also
mein Rekord über fünf Kilometer ist,
ich weiß die Zeit nicht,
aber fünf Minuten zwölf
pro Kilometer.
Über exakt fünf Kilometer.
Also kann man sich ja ausrechnen. Das sind dann irgendwie
27 Minuten oder irgendwie sowas.
Oder?
Fünf mal fünf, 25.
Und dann noch irgendwie
zwölf Sekunden oder so drauf.
Ja, das sind ziemlich
genau irgendwie so sechs und siebenundzwanzig
irgendwie so. Sechsundzwanzig
noch etwas.
Ja.
Aber da bin ich wirklich auch halb
deadgear danach.
Also das ist wirklich das Maximum,
was ich packe. Da bin ich wirklich,
da bin ich richtig im Arsch danach.
Fünfzwölf pro
Kilo. Das ist wirklich,
da bin ich wirklich
richtig im Arsch danach.
Paar Kilo sind, ja, ja, ich
hab also
Peak-Gewicht hatte ich
108,5
und jetzt hab ich so ungefähr
88,5. Also
20 Kilo, ziemlich genau 20 Kilo.
Sind weg,
das ist seit
zwei, drei Jahren, innerhalb
von zwei, drei Jahren, drei Jahre oder so
hat das gedauert, bis ich das
abgenommen habe. Wie groß? Ich bin 1,74.
Also ich bin immer noch zu dick,
aber nicht mal so dick wie früher.
Ich bin mittlerweile
von der Optik her, würde ich
sagen,
ich glaube, die
meisten Leute,
die mich sehen,
glauben nicht,
dass ich
13 Kilometer am Stück rennen kann.
Also ich bin nicht mehr so
so fett wie früher.
Ich bin jetzt aber auch nicht der Dünnste.
Also ich sehe jetzt nicht unbedingt gerade
ja, Langstreckenläufer
mäßig aus.
Also ich glaube, die meisten Leute
würden das echt falsch einschätzen.
Wenn die mich nicht kennen und ich denen
nicht schon ein bisschen was erzählt habe. Ich glaube, die meisten Leute, wenn die mich einfach nur
sehen würden, würden die sagen,
wenn du ihn fragst, müsste man so ein Bild zeigen,
schafft dieser Mann 13 Kilometer
am Stück halbwegs
geschwind, dann würden die sagen nie im Leben.
Geht
mittlerweile, ja.
Danke schön für den Sub.
Ja, jetzt habe ich mich, ich weiß gar nicht, wie ich jetzt
von da dazu gekommen bin.
Ich weiß nicht mehr, worauf ich
raus wollte, ehrlich gesagt.
Welches Monitoring Tool macht dir am meisten Spaß?
Oh, das ist, das ist ein fieses,
ähm,
weil mein Chef entschieden hat, der ist Storage-Experte
und der darf das.
Das ist eine fiese Frage, weil ich habe es da schon
öfters gesagt, so richtig
toll finde ich keins.
Es gibt kein Monitoring Tool,
wo ich wirklich sagen würde, ey,
damit macht es mir richtig Spaß zu arbeiten.
Ich habe ein Herz für Nagios,
nicht, dass ich
neuen Nagios einführen möchte,
irgendwo. Ich mag das noch von früher,
würde ich aber heute gar nicht mehr verwenden.
Also, Zabbix
ist auch so ein Kack. Ist auch nicht
für aktuelle Sachen wirklich gut geeignet,
mehr, gerade wenn man viele Metriken einsammelt.
Also, ich würde sagen, so rund oben,
noch am wenigsten
nervig
bin ich die Kombination aus
Prometheus.
Da hast du aber das Problem,
da fehlt dir so viel bei.
Prometheus ist ja nur
Metric Collection.
Du musst dir überlegen,
okay, wie kommst du überhaupt an die Metriken?
Das heißt, du musst überall irgendwelche Exporter
installieren.
Du willst ja vielleicht nicht nur Metriken von deinem System sammeln,
das heißt, du brauchst vielleicht noch
muss gucken, dass du es in deine Anwendung
einbaust, plus, wenn du so
Sachen machen willst, wie Server Up
Down, geht das ja auch gar nicht so ohne weiteres
von außen zu checken. Da brauchst du noch ein
Blackbox-Exporter. Prometheus
ist eine coole Sache,
aber Prometheus ist sehr viel,
wir bauen uns unser Monitoring selbst.
Das heißt, du brauchst irgendeine Kombination
aus Tools. Ja, du brauchst dann Prometheus,
brauchst Kafana vielleicht für Visualisierung,
ich nehme jetzt mal einfach so die Sachen, die
weit verbreitet sind. Du brauchst Alert Manager
vielleicht für irgendwelche Alerts.
Du brauchst,
was haben wir da sonst noch dabei? Du brauchst
irgendwelche Log Collection.
Du musst dir überlegen, wie mache ich das jetzt?
Bromtail, Loki, wie immer, vielleicht
Elasticsearch. Wie machst du vielleicht
eine Langzeit-Archivierung von deinen
Metriken? Also Prometheus ist kein
Monitoring-Tool.
Im klassischen Sinne
als Standalone-Lösung.
Prometheus ist so ein Kern des Monitorings,
was man, wo man viel
drum herum bauen muss. Also Prometheus,
Prometheus Monitor, also wenn einer sagt, ich mache
Prometheus Monitoring, dann ist das Blödsinn.
Das ist ein Teil
von einem ganzen Monitoring-Stack,
den man dafür braucht heutzutage, um das
das, ja,
schöne, wie man sagt, Observability
zu erreichen. Gibt ja für alle
irgendwelche bescheuerten Buzzwords.
Da ist enorm viel drum herum,
was man da bauen muss. Also wenn man Prometheus
nimmt, muss sehr viel
drum herum gestrickt werden noch.
Womit? Also viele Monitoring-Lösungen
heute sind echt so, wir bauen uns
unser Monitoring selbst.
Wohingegen früher so die klassischen Sachen,
so was wie Nagios oder auch Checkmk
noch und
wie heißt dieses Windows-Ding
noch mal?
Windows-Monitoring.
Wie heißt dieser Krempel noch mal?
PRTG, ja, ja, genau!
PRTG.
Das sind
so die
klassischen Dinger mit
möglichst viel out of the box zu liefern ja zabbix ist cool zabbix hat aber mit moderner
infrastruktur mit modernen moderne monitoring so seine probleme zabbix ist gut für die klassischen
monitoring aufgaben also sprich gucken ist der port offen gucken antwortet der server noch ja
mittlerweile kannst du ja auch in zabbix wenn auch super umständlich prometheus metriken abfragen
aber wo zabbix komplett rein scheißt sind traces zum beispiel oder loks kannst du komplett vergessen
mit zabbix und es gibt also open telemetry sachen collect mit zabbix vergiss es da gibt es gibt es
ein paar feature request bei zabbix und die sagen selbst die zabbix infrastruktur ist einfach nicht
dafür gemacht ja auch dashboards und grafiken sind in zabbix auf denen auf denen ja also hier auf den
auf den werbebildern von zabbix
zabbix sieht das ganz cool aus ja wenn du dir die werbebilder von zabbix anguckt da denkst du dir ey ist ja ein halbes grafana aber ne ne ne ne leute wenn ihr schon mal ein zabbix dashboard vor euch hattet versus ein grafana dashboard und da ein bisschen drin rumklickt werdet ihr feststellen grafana ist wirklich nicht nur ein bisschen vorne raus was visualisierung angeht ja und auch bedienung der dashboards sondern grafana ist wirklich diesen klassischen zabbix dashboard das
was ist ein besonders großer abstand vielleicht nicht lichtjahre aber sagen wir mal welten voraus ja grafana versus versus zabbix was so visualisierungen des sport angeht die machen da viel
aber merkt halt einfach wo er zabbix herkommt techMK übrigens auch nicht besser was so grafiken angeht also ich glaube die beste monitoring lösung gibt es tatsächlich nicht es ist sehr viel strickt ihr selbst was und dementsprechend so richtig happy dass ich sagen würde ey das ist so das monitoring utilisieren ist ganz toll so im
inhaltsystem k behöver ich mehr
und dementsprechend so richtig happy dass ich sagen würde, ey das ist so dis monitoring lösung,ynnivesieren ist einfach eigentlich ne an Biology,
denn es gibt ja auch ganz viele Schriftfillierung an call firms,
da haben wir ja die misinformation aus dem brasiler und die Racejes,
Das Monitoring Kombination an Tools meiner Wahl, irgendwie hat alles was, was mich nervt. Für simple Sachen, wenn man einfach nur sagt, hey, ich habe ein paar Kisten daheim, ein paar Raspberry Pis und will da ein bisschen was überwachen, kann man klassisches Zeug nehmen wie Zabbix, wobei Zabbix Lernkurve extrem steil ist.
Man kann sich auch ein Prometheus installieren und sagen, hey, ich haue mir einfach ein Node-Exporter auf alle Kisten drauf, aber mit den Anforderungen dazu, was du alles collecten möchtest, steigt die Komplexität enorm.
Spätestens wenn du bei Traces und Logs ankommst und bei vielen Metriken und Archivierungen dazu und Alerts verschicken, dann brauchst du einen kompletten Berg an Monitoring Tools dafür.
Ich glaube, dass das auch eines der Gründe ist.
Warum so Plattformen wie Datadog und sowas, auch aufgrund ihres hohen Preises, es vergeht ja im Prinzip kein Tag, wo es nicht irgendwelche Datadog-Pricing-Meme-Posts auf Reddit gibt.
Deswegen sind solche Plattformen wahrscheinlich auch immer noch sehr beliebt, weil es die Möglichkeit bietet, so vieles wie möglich irgendwie halbwegs schön out of the box zu kriegen.
Und es gibt keine Open-Source-Plattformen.
Auch wenn ich kein großer Datadog-Benutzer bin, muss ich sagen.
Ich kenne das auch nur zum größten Teil, außer mal hier, ich klicke ein bisschen in der Trial rum, kenne ich das auch nur aus den Reddit-Meme-Posts.
Aber es muss ja einen Grund haben, warum das weiterhin so beliebt ist.
Ja, manche sagen auch, scheiß auf Prometheus, Grafana und Gedöns, wir machen Elasticsearch mit allem, was dazu gehört.
Also bei Elasticsearch ist es dann...
Och, Leute, helft mir mal.
Was bei Elasticsearch?
Es ist Elasticsearch, Kibana...
Ähm...
Logstash...
Keine Ahnung.
Habe ich zu wenig mitgemacht, dass ich weiß.
Ich glaube, Kibana, Logstash, Elasticsearch, gell?
Ist es, glaube ich, bei denen die Kombination, die du bei denen brauchst.
Wieder Sachen collect...
Ja, und dann noch irgendwelche Collector-Geschichten, ja.
Ja, da gibt es doch diesen Influx...
Diesen Influx-DB...
Influx-DB-Stack, das ist dann Influx-DB...
Und...
Den anderen Kram, den ich vergessen habe, weil ihn keiner benutzt.
Telegraf und...
Was ist da? Ja, das gibt...
Also es gibt keins, was mich rundum glücklich macht, ja.
Ja, Check-MK ist auch eklig.
Ich mag Check-MK nicht.
Ich muss Check-MK auf der Arbeit benutzen.
Aber ich mag Check-MK nicht.
Ich kenne mich mittlerweile brauchbar in Check-MK aus.
Ich würde mich aber wahrscheinlich...
Also...
Wenn alles andere passen würde und ich einen Job suchen würde, ja.
Warum nicht?
Aber wenn ich einen Check-MK-Heavy-Job hätte, so nach dem Motto Check-MK-Admin.
Oh, ne.
Das würde ich wahrscheinlich nicht machen wollen.
Dankeschön, Mick, da hinten für den Sub.
Das ist auch meine Erfahrung, ja.
Also die richtig guten Technik-Leute, die ich kenne, das sind...
Ich will nicht sagen ohne Ausnahme, vielleicht vergesse ich jetzt irgendeinen.
Da sind aber zum weit größten Teil Leute, die auch privat gerne an Technik-Zeug rumbasteln.
Was ich in der Mittagspause im Homeoffice mache.
Ich mache so gut wie keine Mittagspause.
Ich futter sogar manchmal am Rechner.
Ich gehe lieber morgens eine halbe Stunde rennen und futter dann am Rechner.
Ich würde sogar so weit gehen, dass sogar...
Also auch wenn ich vielleicht manchmal fünf Minuten länger renne, als in einer halben Stunde abgezogen kriege,
dass ich sogar Minus mache dadurch.
Also Minus, Minus ist ein falsches Wort für, ja.
Aber sagen wir mal so, was der Arbeitgeber Plus macht,
weil ich habe schon so oft abends beispielsweise noch ins Teams reingeguckt.
Ja.
Oder irgendeinem Entwickler was geschrieben, mich abends noch mal kurz eingeloggt,
weil irgendwie einer meinte, ey Max, sorry, ich habe es jetzt erst gesehen
und ich bin dann irgendwie zurückgekommen vom Rennen oder vom Fahrradfahren und sage,
ey, weißt du was, ich logge mich noch mal kurz ein.
Das sind immer mal so zehn Minuten, Viertelstunde, die ich dann auch gar nicht ins...
Ich wollte gerade aus Versehen den Namen von unserem Abrechnungssystem sagen,
was wahrscheinlich keine gute Idee ist.
Was ich dann auch meistens nicht in mein Abrechnungssystem eintrage.
Also wahrscheinlich macht bei meiner Art der Pause und das Mittagessen sogar der Arbeitgeber,
plus ich esse total oft auch vor dem Rechner.
Ich gehe runter in die Küche, da ich mal nicht vor dem Rechner sitze,
aber ich habe auch schon oft genug vor dem Rechner gefuttert.
Also default versuche ich runter zu gehen, in die Küche mal kurz mich hinzusetzen,
nicht am Rechner, aber ich habe so oft auch schon vor dem Rechner.
Also ich würde sagen 50-50.
Hallo in diesem Video nur ganz kurz.
Bist du da mit Gedanken am PC arbeiten oder kannst du das abschalten?
Wenn ich Rennen gehe und Fahrradfahren gehe, meinst du, da kann ich abschalten, das ist kein Problem.
Gerade Fahrradfahren.
Ohne Scheiß, Leute.
Ist ja noch nicht so, als würde ich jetzt super lange Fahrrad fahren.
Also ich habe mir das erste Fahrrad letztes Jahr im August gekauft.
Oder irgendwie so in dem Dreh.
Und dann hatte ich ja den Unfall und lange Zeit kein Fahrrad.
Also es ist nicht so, dass ich jetzt jahrelang schon Fahrrad fahren würde.
Aber Fahrradfahren ist, glaube ich, eines der besten Sachen, um sich abzulenken.
Fahrradfahren ist, wenn man es nicht übertreibt, genau die richtige Kombination aus Anstrengung, aber nicht zu anstrengend.
Und klar, man kann natürlich auch Berge hochbrettern und man ist kurz vorm Umfallen, das habe ich auch schon gemacht.
Und ich habe so eine Runde bei uns hier, da geht es 430 Meter den Berg hoch.
Da bist du im Arsch danach.
Aber Fahrradfahren ist genau, also ohne E-Bike.
Übrigens, ich bin der Meinung, E-Bike ist immer noch, ist eine super Erfindung, weil es auch Leuten ermöglicht,
die ansonsten ja vielleicht nicht so die passende Base Fitness haben, Fahrrad zu fahren.
Das ist eine super Sache.
Bist du da schon mal in Frankfurt mit dem Rad?
Ja.
Aber noch nie auf die Arbeit, nur nach Frankfurt gefahren und dann wieder zurück.
Sind 54, 55 Kilometer so in dem Dreh.
Also hin und zurück zusammen.
Und das ist eines der besten Kombinationen aus, es ist anstrengend genug, dass du nicht jetzt irgendwie über komplizierte Sachen nachdenken kannst.
So, ah hier, was habe ich da, warum habe ich da einen Syntaxfehler?
Das geht nicht auf dem Fahrrad.
Ja, aber es ist nicht zu anstrengend, dass du gar nicht so ein bisschen vor dich hindenken kannst.
Also Fahrradfahren ist wirklich die optimale.
Ich kenne nichts besseres.
Also auch in der kurzen Zeit, wo ich das mache, ich kenne nichts besseres zum Kopf entspannen als Fahrradfahren.
Das ist super, super Geschichte.
Besser als Rennen.
Wenn du rennst, ist es potenziell deutlich anstrengender als Fahrradfahren.
Das ist bei mir definitiv auch nicht Zone 2.
Auf gar keinen Fall ist das Zone 2.
Ne, das ist wie gesagt am Stück.
Also ich glaube mein Rekord über 10 Kilometer ist, glaube ich knapp eine Stunde.
Bisschen über eine Stunde, was ungefähr 6 Minuten pro Kilometer sind.
Ja, eine Stunde, Stunde 1 oder so oder Stunde 30 oder sowas.
Und das ist schon ein bisschen her, also wahrscheinlich wäre ich heute noch ein bisschen schneller, wenn ich es wirklich...
Ja, ich bin bereit für den Halbmarathon.
Ich warte nur drauf, bis mal wirklich schönes Wetter ist.
Dann will ich die Strecke rennen von hier Hanau, Seligenstadt und zurück.
Das sind ungefähr 22 Kilometer.
Dann nehme ich auch die GoPro mit.
Das nehme ich auf.
Hast du irgendwie die Ernährung umgestellt?
Also bei mir ist es 90% mehr die Bewegung gewesen.
Ernährung habe ich nicht wirklich umgestellt.
Das einzige, was ich jetzt mache, ist vielleicht, dass ich minimal gesünder futtere.
Ich esse ab und zu mal was Gesundes, sagen wir es mal so.
Ich esse ab und zu mal sowas wie Kartoffeln und Spargel und Tomaten und sowas.
Aber das meiste ist immer noch der gleichen Shit, den ich früher gefuttert habe.
Das einzige, was ich mache, ist...
Ich esse vielleicht einen Hauch...
Weniger Mittag als früher.
Aber das ist es nicht, letztendlich.
Und der Grund, warum ich einen Hauch weniger als früher futtere, ist auch mit...
Weil wenn ich mittags eine Runde rennen gehen will, geht das mit gar zu vollem Bauch nicht.
Ne, ne, Nudel mit Lachs heute wieder.
Ne, heute Nudel mit Bolognese.
Also ich esse vielleicht mittags einen Hauch weniger und vielleicht auch einen Hauch gesünder.
Aber bei mir ist es tatsächlich zu 95%.
Nur die Mehrbewegung gewesen, die dazu geführt hat, dass es weniger geworden ist.
Man darf das ja auch nicht unterschätzen, dass man dadurch, dass man sich mehr bewegt, insgesamt auch mehr Hunger hat und mehr frisst.
Wir wollten auf Grafana und nun haben sie gemerkt, dass 25% nicht funktioniert und jetzt starten sie es.
Ja.
Das hätte ich denen tatsächlich gleich sagen können, dass Grafana nur ein ganz kleiner Teil von dem ist, was man dafür braucht.
Ne, allein schon...
Die Daten müssen ja da irgendwie rein.
Also irgendwas muss die Daten ja collecten.
Irgendwie mit irgendwas musst du Grafana...
Ja, connecten, dass das überhaupt was zu visualisieren hat.
Oh, okay.
Leute, ich habe zweieinhalb Stunden am Stück nur geschwätzt.
Wir müssen uns jetzt mal ein paar Videos angucken.
Ich...
Tut der Hals...
Ganz Hals ist schon trocken, ja.
Naja, aber sagen wir mal so.
30, 30 zu fahren alleine...
Ähm...
Längere Strecke ist jetzt auch nicht gerade ohne, ja.
Also ich packe das mit meinem Bike auch.
Aber nur auf gutem Untergrund.
Dann geht das sogar ganz, ganz brauchbar.
Aber am Stück würde ich das auch nicht.
Das würde ich auch nicht fahren wollen, also...
Das über zwei, drei Stunden...
Muss erstens die Strecke mitmachen und das ist auch nicht ohne.
Das ist schon recht zackig, ja.
25 ist eine super, super Geschwindigkeit, finde ich.
Ah, also...
25 ist auf, auf geraden, gut, gut gebauten Straßen, finde ich eigentlich eine ganz gute, ganz angenehme Geschwindigkeit, wenn man längere Strecken fährt.
Das ist weit schneller, als das, was der 0815-Fahrradfahrer fährt.
Ne, habe ich noch nicht gesehen. Welches meinst du?
Okay, Leute. Ich habe den Chat.
Den Chat geschafft, okay.
Dann lasst uns mal gucken.
Irgendwas Kurzes, was wir uns hier anschauen können auf YouTube.
Da muss nichts Kurzes sein.
Call the compiler, fax it your code.
What?
Moment.
Reply gleich 7.
Steht das da drunter für das Fax?
Sekunde, ich muss kurz Pause machen. Spinnwurm.
Wo davon wieder?
Ne, gell? Wo davon geht's? Stream is, stream is okay.
...
Was hat er da am Start? Das ist ja ein geiler Telefonhörer.
Das Ding brauche ich auch.
Das sieht, das sieht sowohl oldschool, als auch irgendwie so, so retro-mäßig nice aus.
...
Das ist das Hamburger Phone.
Und ein paar Zeilen Bash-Skript.
Ich glaube, es ist gar nicht schwierig, sowas zu bauen.
Aber eine coole Idee.
Stimmt, OCR brauchst du...
Ja, OCR, ein paar Zeilen Bash-Skript brauchst du dafür.
Ich glaube, dass die Implementierung davon sogar relativ easy ist.
Ach, Source-Code ist hier.
Guck mal, kann man sich sogar angucken.
Kalibri, ja.
Im Prinzip sind das ein paar...
Okay, es sind Python-Skripts, es sind keine Bash-Skripts.
Aber geht in die Richtung, ne?
Was haben wir denn hier?
Ein Fire-Ship-Video!
Hat Fax nicht eine kacke Auflösung?
Ja, aber die Schrift ist groß.
Das sollte für OCR nicht so sehr das Problem sein.
Sicherlich klappt es manchmal nicht, hat er auch geschrieben.
Aber im Großen und Ganzen, ich glaube, das ist schon ganz gut.
Google-Secret-Algorithm exposed.
Was? Google?
Das habe ich gar nicht mitgekriegt.
Habt ihr das mitbekommen?
Googles Suchalgorithmus wurde auf GitHub geleakt?
Das ist doch bestimmt irgendwas anderes, oder?
Das habe ich nicht mitgekriegt.
Teile davon? Ach so.
Ja.
Google-Search-Ranking-Algorithm actually works.
If the secret ever got out, Google would implode,
because SEO-Experts would...
would get every keyword to link to a landing page for fake Viagra-Pills.
Unfortunately, Google accidentally pushed thousands of Docs...
So, Search-Optimization ist auch, was sich jeder Online-Marketing-Typ, glaube ich,
mittlerweile in seinen Lebenslauf schreibt, oder?
Oder unter seinen Skills...
...dokuments to GitHub...
Und die meisten kriegen es wahrscheinlich nicht mehr hin.
...of all places, a website owned by their Bing-rival Microsoft,
that provide an unprecedented look behind the curtain of Google Search.
As a bit of an SEO-Guru myself, I was left shocked and utterly devastated
when I found out that...
Google has not been totally honest about the Algorithm.
In today's video, we'll take a look at what's inside these Documents,
and find out if Google has been living up to its credo of...
Don't be evil.
It is May 31st, 2024, and you're watching The Code Report.
When Google was founded in the late 90s by Larry and Sergei at Stanford,
it was all based on the idea that a search engine could be handled entirely with an Algorithm,
which at the time was a radical idea that differed from search engines like Ask Jeeves and Yahoo,
which relied on unscalable human curation.
They wrote a legendary paper called...
The Anatomy of a Large-Scale Hyper-Textural Web Search Engine,
that detailed something called the Page-Writer.
Das ist mal High-IQ-Titel, oder?
Von 1998, ja.
Dürfen nicht vergessen...
Yahoo!
...hatte zweimal die Möglichkeit, Google zu kaufen, und sie haben es zweimal nicht gemacht.
Das erste Mal war, als die das hier also quasi implementiert hatten,
wollten die das, glaube ich, für eine Million Dollar...
Ich erzähle es jetzt aus dem Kopf, ich bin mir nicht ganz sicher, ob das alles...
so hundertprozentig korrekt ist.
Ich glaube, damals wollten sie für eine Million oder zehn Millionen...
Für wenig Geld, ja, im Vergleich zu heute,
wollten sie damals ihre Suchmaschine, ihren Algorithmus und wie das funktioniert,
wollten sie an Yahoo verkaufen, und Yahoo hat gesagt,
Piss dich, Alde!
Danach haben sie Google gestartet, lief gut, und dann hätte nach ein paar Jahren
Yahoo nochmal die Möglichkeit gehabt, Google zu kaufen,
für damals immer noch einen lächerlichen Preis,
und sie haben es immer noch nicht gewollt.
Und jetzt hat es sich aus, Yahoo, seit ein paar Jahren.
Und jetzt würde ich an Googles Stelle jetzt auch sagen,
was ist denn das überhaupt für eine komische Sprache?
Was ist das?
Was sehe ich hier überhaupt?
Ist das irgendwas Google-intern gewurschteltes, oder?
Es sieht ein bisschen aus wie...
Ich habe keine Ahnung, wie das aussieht, vielleicht ein bisschen wie Dart oder so,
aber es ist nicht Dart.
Alexia ist das, okay.
Ah, habt ihr das daran erkannt, an der Endung, oder?
Nee, wie Erlang sieht es nicht aus.
Für Erlang hat es zu wenig Klammern.
Ihr habt das...
Ach, der sagt das in dem...
Der Chat wieder hier auf richtig Pfeifett gemacht,
in Wirklichkeit habt ihr einfach nur das Video geguckt.
Aber...
Zum Pfeifett sein gehört auch zu zeigen, dass man Pfeifett ist, Chat.
Interessant ist, dass der geleakte Code die Elixir-Programmungs-Language benutzt,
was Google nicht normalerweise intern benutzen würde.
Aber jetzt gehen wir zu den echten Lügen.
In der Vergangenheit hat Google...
Das habe ich mich... Ohne Mist, genau das habe ich mich auch gerade gefragt.
Das wurde wieder einmal in den Leaked-Dokumenten bestätigt,
was es als Klick- und Impressionssignale für Kratzen bezeichnet.
Es sieht also so aus, als ob Klicks eigentlich wichtig sind, nicht überraschend.
Ein weiterer potenzieller Fib ist, dass es so sieht,
basierend auf diesen Dokumenten,
dass die Daten, die die User in den Chrome-Browser sammeln,
die Such-Rankungen beeinflussen.
Nicht überrascht.
Und eine andere Sache, die nicht überraschend ist,
ist, dass Backlinks immer noch zählen.
Es ist nicht der einfache Page-Rank-Algorithmus, wie es früher war,
aber es ist immer noch wichtig, diese hohen Qualitäts-Backlinks zu bekommen.
Und letztendlich, das schockierendste, was nicht überraschend ist,
ist, dass wirkliche Menschen für Rating- und Whitelisting-Kritik-Kontent verwendet werden.
Z.B. im Bereich...
Das dachte ich mir, ja.
Dass da für manche Sachen sich...
Ja, ja, das habe ich im Vorfeld aber auch schon gedacht.
...Covid-Autority oder Is-Election-Autority für das verwendet werden.
Und durch meine Befragung habe ich auch diesen,
namens WebRef-Kompakt-Flat-Property-Value gefunden.
Was?
Der scheint die echte Form der Erde zu verstecken zu sein.
Nun, ich bin kein Urologist, aber insgesamt sieht diese Leak ziemlich schlecht aus.
Ich kann nicht glauben, dass eine große Kooperation uns lügen würde,
aber die echte Tragedie hier ist die Web selbst.
In den frühen Tagen war Google der beste Weg, interessante Webseiten und Forums zu finden,
die von randomen Schwierigkeiten hergestellt wurden,
aber heutzutage sind die Top-Rankungen fast vollständig dominiert
von autoritären Seiten wie Wikipedia und Reddit,
in Zufall von bezahlbaren Advertisern.
Und es ist so, was ist eigentlich der Grund für eine Webseite heutzutage,
wenn AI einfach nur deine Webseite überschreiten wird,
und du nie einen Klick durchkommst?
SEO ist schon lange tot, und jetzt mit diesem Leak ist es noch totter.
Das war der Code-Report, danke fürs Zuschauen,
und wir sehen uns in der nächsten Folge.
Also, so wirklich viel über das Leak gelernt haben wir jetzt aber nicht, oder?
Außer, dass Klicks zählen,
und am Ende noch irgendwelche Menschen wichtigen Content whitelisten.
Oh, sorry, äh, äh, wie darf man das nennen?
Whitelist ist nicht mehr erlaubt. Ähm, allowlisten, allowlisten, okay?
CEO is dead, girl.
Immer wenn ich so einen Livestream sehe, ja, immer wenn ich so einen Livestream sehe,
dann denke ich, irgendein Channel wurde wieder gehackt,
und Fake-Elon-Mask-Crypto-Scam läuft.
Aber das scheint ja wirklich ein echter Tesla-Livestream zu sein jetzt.
Okay, was haben wir denn sonst noch hier?
Oh, das ist mir zu advanced.
Auch wenn der Typ wirklich gute Videos macht, von dem habe ich schon ein paar Mal,
paar Videos geguckt, das ist immer richtig, richtig nice Erklärung gewesen,
aber das ist mir zu high IQ.
Quasi asynchrona, äh, wie heißt das, äh, key, key, äh, Schlüsselaustausch.
Sind das, sind das Bob und Alice?
Ja, der macht gute Videos, aber das ist mir jetzt, das ist mir jetzt zu high IQ.
Was haben wir denn sonst noch hier?
Seven HTML-Features you probably don't know.
Ja, da kannst du von, es sind nur drei Minuten, das können wir uns mal angucken.
Ich, ich, ich wette mit euch, dass ich, ich meine, ich bin ja nicht der krasseste Web-Hacker mehr, ne?
Ich wette mit euch, dass es tatsächlich stimmt, dass ich diese sieben HTML-Features noch nicht knowe.
Drei Minuten, das müssen wir uns jetzt kurz angucken, so.
Welche know ich denn nicht?
Ist das, ist das AI-Voice? Ist das AI-Voice, Leute?
Nee, nee, das ist keine AI-Voice. Ich glaube, das ist keine AI-Voice.
Ich glaube, das ist keine AI-Voice.
Okay.
Also.
Dann zeig mal her.
Easy, kenne ich. Habe ich mir erst letzte Woche ein Video zu angeguckt.
Ja.
Ich habe es noch nie selbst ausprobiert, wusste ich aber, dass es das gibt. Es gibt jetzt Pop-Ups im Browser. Native Pop-Ups im Browser. Man braucht keine fünf Seiten JavaScript mehr dafür.
Und man kann das sogar halbwegs ordentlich CSS stylen.
Ja, kenne ich. Kenne ich.
Ja, kenne ich. Also, nur noch sechs Stück, die ich nicht kennen kann.
Wusste ich auch, dass es das gibt.
Ja.
Das kenne ich nicht. Kennt ihr das?
Ach.
Das ist so ein.
Wie nennt sich das in den ganzen Java Free demand, Dropdown?
Nein, nicht dropdown.
Wie heißt denn das Ding?
Expander oder sowas, gell?
Nennt sich das in den ganzen GUI-Frameworks immer.
Ja, Expander. Ja, genau.
Das ist cool.
Das wusste ich nicht, dass es das gibt.
Das ist mir neu.
Ja, ist das uralt?
Das hier, Datalist-Attribute.
Okay, das wusste ich auch nicht, dass es neu ist.
Okay.
Ähm, warum kann ich nicht einfach sagen, CSS-Klick, äh, wie heißt das?
No, no, no, da gibt es doch so ne, no event, ne, no.
Ich hab vergessen, wie das, es gibt für CSS sowas, das macht genau das gleiche.
Okay, dann ignoriert das Klick-Events.
Das gibt es jetzt sowohl über CSS als auch, ne, das heißt irgendwie anders, was ich meine.
Ja, no Pointer-Events. Ja, genau, richtig. Ja, ja.
No Pointer-Events, genau das meine ich.
Wusste ich nicht.
Ja, Pointer-Events, ja.
Ja.
Moment, Ding, Ding, das ist neu?
Okay.
This has a very specific usage, but covers a scenario which was previously handled exclusively through third-party libraries.
Another similar feature is the HTML Capture Attribute.
This can be added on file input elements and allows users to use their devices and capture images using either the front or the back camera.
No.
Okay.
Das wusste ich nicht, dass das ein Ding ist.
In der Tat nicht schlecht.
Ich persönlich hätte jetzt eigentlich gedacht, dass das anders gelöst ist.
Du sagst Typ File und dann klickst du da drauf und dann wählst du halt die Kamera aus.
Aber okay, das ist nice, dass es sowas gibt.
Note that this isn't supported on regular browsers, but you should have no compatibility issues on mobile devices.
We didn't discuss progressive web apps in this video, but things are moving rapidly here as well.
Please let me know.
Außer, wisst ihr, wo bei progressive web apps die Sachen nicht rapidly moven?
Ihr werdet es euch wahrscheinlich schon denken.
Safari.
If you are interested in exploring this topic in more detail, if you feel like you learned something, you'll probably find some of these videos interesting as well.
Auf Safari moved fast nix rapidly.
Until next time, thank you for watching.
Leider.
Ich will nicht so weit gehen, dass Safari der neue Internet Explorer ist.
So schlimm ist es nicht.
Aber Safari ist schon ziemlich lahm.
Was haben wir denn hier?
I hacked.
Was?
I hacked time to recover 3 million from a Bitcoin.
Haben wir das nicht schon mal gesehen?
Das kommt mir bekannt vor, dieses Video in Kombination mit diesem Channel.
Aber das ist 4 Tage alt.
Muss was Neues sein.
Aber 21 Minuten ist mir zu lang jetzt.
Guck mal hier.
Der hatte ein ähnliches schon mal.
Katze besucht jeden Tag die Sparkasse.
Excellent.
Cat Content.
Das brauch ich jetzt.
Kamera 2.
Okay.
Sie ist immer pünktlich, liebt den Kundenkontakt und schnurrt beim Streichen.
Sie ist immer pünktlich.
Schöne Farbkombination.
Sie ist immer pünktlich, liebt den Kundenkontakt und schnurrt beim Streichen.
Sie ist immer pünktlich, schnurrt beim Streichladen.
Ach.
Sie ist immer publikat und pillars conheiglich.
Wir haben jetzt 3.
Schöne Farbkombination.
Für viele Bündnisse Lancashire, b Spotify,
f Twitter undaco.
Habenобщеツbe shampoo gue.
Hype eigentlich der.
Diese Bank-Filiale hat eine ganz besondere Mitarbeitung.
Leider habe ich noch keinen.
Also, Tschecho ist die hier unten.
Jeden Tag um 8 Uhr früh vor der Tür, wenn wir kommen, Maut ist sicher und wir müssen sie reinlassen.
Auf ihrem Lieblingsplatz, direkt neben dem Schalter, hat Mimi...
Ich könnte wetten, die mag das, weil es da so warm drin ist. Also gerade im Winter ist er da bestimmt schön warm.
...fest im Blick.
Kunden finden es auch ganz toll, wenn die in die Sparkasse reinkommen und sie sehen gleich auf den ersten Blick, dass die Katze da ist
und kommen teilweise sogar wegen der Katze in die Sparkasse rein.
Ganz ehrlich, ich würde auch nur wegen der Katze in die Sparkasse kommen.
Was soll ich sonst in der Sparkasse?
Chat jetzt ermutigt ihn nicht noch. Jetzt muss ich ihn gleich wieder temporär excluden vom Chat.
Maut kommt seither jeden Tag pünktlich zur Ladenöffnung.
Ihre rechtmäßigen Besitzer suchen die Bankangestellten bislang vergebens.
Die Mittagspausen nutzen wir eigentlich oft, um mit ihr zu spielen, um sie zu...
Ey, die hat doch bestimmt einen Chip im Ohr, oder?
...für dann zu streicheln. Man kriegt dann selber den Kopf hängen klar, kann mal kurz durchatmen und ist dann wieder bereit für den Nachmittag.
Also das genießen wir eigentlich sehr.
Die Mäuse liegen zwar leider alle im katzensicheren Safe, auf Jagd geht Mimi aber trotzdem.
Wir finden es halt toll, dass eine Katze da ist und dass man sie immer wieder mal...
Ja, okay. Ist okay.
Cello, du hast, genau, du hast einmal Aski spermfrei streicheln können.
Und vor allem, dass sie halt die Zuneigung zu uns hat und die uns auch zeigt.
Ja...
Naja, die hat uns um den Finger gewickelt und von daher ist sie jetzt da und sie bleibt auch da.
Ja, die geht auch von alleine immer.
Komm mal weg!
Was haben wir denn hier sonst noch?
Das haben wir schon geguckt, oder?
Was war denn das hier mit dem Ha...
Du willst dein Haus, aber start hier.
Oh, das ist doch bestimmt wieder der dritte Aufguss vom gleichen Thema, oder?
Wir skippen da mal kurz drüber, ob da was interessantes dabei ist.
Was ist der Unterschied zwischen das...
Was soll da großer Unterschied sein?
Beides steht daheim und surft irgendwelche Services.
Das eine ist halt fertig und das andere bastelt man sich selbst ein bisschen so...
Welches Betriebssystem?
Ja, da kann man sich drüber streiten.
So richtig zufrieden, hundertprozentig bin ich mit Unraid ja auch nicht.
Ah, okay. Das ist, glaube ich, echt der 500. Neuaufguss dieses Themas.
Was ist das?
Oh, das wird viel zu lang.
Ah, selbst gebe ich auch das Ambilight.
Zeig mal her, gibt's da ein bisschen mehr Showcase oder so?
Das ist nur für 15 Minuten.
Ja, das ist...
Okay, das ist schon Overkill-Ambilight.
Kannst trinken, ey. Na ja, gute Idee.
Das ist schon Overkill-Ambilight.
Und ich muss sagen, das ist schon...
Das würde mich schon zu sehr ablenken.
Ich hab auch Ambilight bei mir am Fernsehen.
Allerdings nur...
direkt dahinter...
was die Wand anstrahlt.
So Sachen mit extra LEDs drumherum.
Aber ich glaube, das ist zu distracting.
Ja, vor allem nachdem hier erstmal dunkel ist und da unten geht's dann weiter.
Ich glaube, das ist zu...
zu viel Rauschen so im Auge um das Bild drumherum.
Das hier ist cool, ja.
Hab ich bei mir auch.
Und das geht seit Jahren ohne Probleme.
Also ich hab auch so Nachrüst-Ambilight.
Ich hab keinen Fernseher mit Ambilight.
Ich hab so ein Ding mit Zwischenstecker.
Von welchem Anbieter?
Äh, ich hab...
Streamscreen damals gekauft.
Das gibt es aber nicht mehr.
Die sind pleite.
Die sind dead...
deadge.
Auch wenn es so aussieht, als könnte man das noch kaufen.
Kann man nicht mehr.
Das ist... die sind Streamscreen-Reddit.
Wie groß ist mein Fernseher?
Ich weiß es aus dem Kopf nicht.
Wie groß ist der Fernseher?
Das ist immer noch der gleiche wie vor 7 Jahren.
Also...
Kann man das sich hier irgendwie ableiten, wie groß der Fernseher ist?
Nicht wirklich.
Äh, außer...
Oh, liegt!
Ähm, tja...
Kann man 55 Zoll?
Keiner.
Ja.
Ist immer noch der gleiche.
Ah.
Der grinst immer so.
Was ist das für ein komisches Video?
Kann durchaus sein, 55 Zoll.
Ich weiß es nicht.
Kann auch kleiner sein.
55... Ich hab keine Ahnung.
Groß genug ist er.
Benutzt den eh kaum.
Ich mein, so cool es ist...
Das ist...
Das ist mir echt ein bisschen Overkill mit hier unten und so.
Und neben den Leuten.
Das hier drum herum finde ich nice.
Das gefällt mir bei meinem Ambilight auch.
Aber...
Das andere ist zu heftig.
Was ist das für ein Bild über dir?
Echt? Bist du Art-Enjoyer?
Ja, bin ich.
Wo ist da ein Bild?
Ach, du meinst hinter mir, was ich...
Wo ich mich spiegel?
Okay, müssen wir nochmal gucken.
Spiegel... Spiegelungs...
Spiegelungs-Champ.
Chetke, wo spiegel ich mich schön?
Hier. Hups. Ich kann noob.
Ja, wo spiegel ich mich schön?
Zeig mal her.
Hier.
Ja, das da. Ja.
Richtiger Art-Enjoyer bin ich.
Hier sieht mans. Hier sieht mans ganz gut jetzt.
Ja.
Hier wird... Hier wird Art-Enjoyed.
Ich hab noch mehr Bilder hier hängen.
Aber allesamt
keine...
Keine... Ich kauf mir irgendwie
so ein nachgemachtes Ding auf Ebay oder so.
Alles Original-Bilder.
Aber von niemand bekanntem.
Das sind Bilder, die mein Opa gemalt hat.
Ja.
Korrekt. Rackman.
Und mein Opa konnte ziemlich gut malen.
Ich weiß nicht, ob es das...
Das muss sich ja löschen.
Weil man dort
leicht bekleidete
Mädels drauf gesehen hat.
Auf dem...
Auf dem Gemälden von meinem Opa.
Wobei...
Warte mal. Das Video gibt's doch noch.
Das Video gibt's doch noch.
Oh Gott. Youtube.
Alter. Ich will mein eigenes...
Das Video ist nicht...
Geht das nicht mehr?
Moment. Wie war das?
Warte mal.
Wie ging das nochmal?
What the fuck? Youtube?
Ernsthaft?
Alter.
Youtube.DL...
Nice.
Aber ich kann mein Video runterladen.
Das ist schon mal sehr nice.
Downloaden funktioniert anscheinend von dem Video.
Ja. Da sieht man ein bisschen
Gemälde von meinem Opa.
Moment. Moment. Moment.
In welchem...
In welchem Format lädt er das jetzt überhaupt hier runter?
Kann VLC das abspielen?
Man könnte es auch streamen in VLC.
Hier.
Ich will das F in...
Ja. Eigentlich will ich das schon in...
Oh. Jetzt flutscht's, Leute.
Gachi Bass.
Der Titel ist nicht wirklich...
Und denkt.
So. Jetzt fahr ich auf den Dachboden in dem Video.
Ja.
Ja. Guck mal.
Da sind eher die Sachen,
die er da noch seine Zweite-Weltkrieg-Sachen
und Ängste verarbeitet hat,
der Opa.
Richtig schwere Kost.
Und...
Ja.
Hier sieht man eher so die normalen
Gemälde.
Guck. Der hat richtig...
Ja. Beste Kameraarbeit. Ich weiß.
Ja.
Guck. Da gibt's halt ein bisschen...
Buba.
Ja.
So Sachen hat er gemalt.
Der war echt...
Der war echt nicht schlecht.
Ist das Oma? Nein, nein.
Das ist nicht die Oma.
Ein Bild von der Oma hängt im Wohnzimmer.
Also, wenn sowas Toss ist,
dann weiß ich auch nicht.
Guck mal. Da hinten sind noch mehr.
Da hinten sind noch mehr...
Wenn sowas Toss ist,
dann weiß ich auch nicht.
Ja. Also, der war schon nicht schlecht.
Ja. Und solche...
Das ist übrigens er selbst.
Das ist er selbst.
Also, das ist Kunst.
Das ist nicht Buba Toss.
Guckt's euch an hier.
Ich mein, die...
Die Bilder sind aus allen
seinen Schaffensperioden.
Also, diese über...
Ja. Weiß ich. So über 50 Jahre
oder so, woran er gemalt hat.
Sind die Sachen.
Und...
Man erkennt da schon, dass
er am Anfang
eher halt so sich inspirieren lassen hat.
So bei traditionellen Sachen.
Und dann immer mehr so
seine eigenen Dinger
entwickelt hat. Also, gerade die...
Gerade die älteren
Bilder sind richtig gut.
Die hab ich auch noch alle hier. Die stehen im Trockenen.
Und ein paar, die mir besonders
gut gefallen. Beziehungsweise hauptsächlich
die meiner Mutter gut gefallen.
Die sind hier im Haus... Weil das Haus ist ja
nicht direkt... Gehört ja nicht mir. Das gehört meiner Mutter
nach dem Haus. Und...
Dementsprechend darf die auch entscheiden, was die
bei sich im Haus da hinhängt.
Und da hängen ein paar. Die sind echt nice.
Ist das der Opa, mit dem du
auch mal was aufgenommen hast? Ja.
Ist es. Ist es.
Hatte der nicht auch noch eine Werkstatt?
Ja. Ja. Ja, ich hab...
Ich hab mit meinem Opa mal ein Video aufgenommen.
Ja. Der hatte nicht wirklich Bock dazu
ein Video aufzunehmen, muss man sagen.
Beziehungsweise das Audio
aufzunehmen. Mein Opa sagt
eigentlich die ganze Zeit im Video
irgendwie so...
So, lass mich in Ruhe. So nach dem Motto.
Ne, ne, ne.
Genau. Genau. Mein Opa sagt die ganze Zeit
im Video, ich halte, ich halte
von deinem Gelabere nix.
Ich mag das nicht,
wenn gelabert wird. Das ist so...
Das ist belangloses Gelabere,
was du da machst. Ey.
Objektiv gesehen, er hat Recht.
Ja. Twitch ist
zu fün... Und YouTube auch. Ganz ehrlich.
Ohne dass der Twitch und YouTube
kennt, zu 95%
ist oder zu 99,9%
ist Twitch und YouTube
absolut belangloses
Gelabere.
Der Opa hat es schon durchschaut,
bevor er wusste, welche Plattform das ist.
Du wirst noch Schwerkordel
nachgeben müssen. Genau.
Oh Mann.
Also, mein Opa hat
wie gesagt, der hat nicht nur so
fröhlich, fröhliche
Blümchenbilder gemalt und...
Der hat auch nicht nur nackte Mädels gemalt.
Ich frag mich immer noch, was meine Oma sich dabei
eigentlich gedacht hat.
Wenn da irgendwelche...
Mädels nackig bei ihm im
Atelier gelebt... Keine Ahnung, was
die... Ob das ein Problem für die
war, ich weiß nicht. Also...
Ich, ich hätte mich da
schon gewundert, ja.
Naja. Zumindest,
also, auch ein paar Bilder,
die, die wirklich nice sind.
Man hat's ja am Anfang in dem Video ein bisschen,
teilweise schon gesehen. Der hat ja
auch seine Sachen aus dem Zweiten Weltkrieg
bisschen verarbeitet, so. Und auch diese...
Diese Angst, die man dann
später im Kalten Krieg hatte, so mit
Atombombenangriff und so. Das eine, was ihr da
gerade gesehen habt, ist, ist ein Bild von ihm
gewesen, drei Bilder.
Quasi...
Stadt.
Alles friedlich.
Atombombe schlägt
ein und danach, da habt ihr ja die...
Gab's ja diese Frau mit dem Baby,
die man da gesehen hat in dem einen Bild. Das ist quasi
nach. Also, da war schon
richtig big brain
bei den Themen, die er da verarbeitet hat.
Das ist aber, glaube ich,
also, das ist jetzt kein Bild, was ich mir an die Wand hängen würde.
Das ist vielleicht ein bisschen zu schwere
Kost, ja.
Frau läuft mit Baby nach
Atombombeneinschlag durch das verwüstete
Dorf. Das ist vielleicht nix, was man
sich in Flur oder ins
Wohnzimmer hängen möchte. Aber da hat
er schon ein paar aktuelle Sachen der jeweiligen
Zeit verarbeitet.
Auch echt nicht schlecht.
Was der Opa da so gemalt hat.
Fürs Gästeklo.
Näh. Ja, wahrscheinlich
war das ganz normal, ja.
Es gibt
tatsächlich in Hanau
hängen ein paar Bilder von ihm.
Also,
in manchen Gebäuden hängen von meinem Opa ein paar Bilder.
So über Hanau verteilt
in manchen öffentlichen Gebäuden.
Ist euch aber wahrscheinlich noch nie aufgefallen,
falls das irgendjemand
mal...
Weil ihr wisst, wie mein Opa hieß.
Also solltet ihr mal schon
sie gesehen haben in manchen öffentlichen Gebäuden
in Hanau, dann wisst ihr nicht, dass
welche von meinem Opa sind.
Gibt's ein paar.
Ansonsten habe ich die
trocken und sicher gelagert
auf dem Dachboden.
Ne, solche
Dinge hängen nicht in öffentlichen Gebäuden rum.
Ich glaube, das halten die meisten
ähm, ja
Ämter
und solche Sachen
nicht angemessen.
Aktbilder
im Flur hängen zu haben. Aber die Frage
hast du schon zurecht, warum nicht, ja? Vielleicht
haben die Leute dann auch nicht so
werden dann nicht so aggressiv, wenn sie so lange warten müssen.
Auf der anderen Seite
heute hat jeder ein Handy dabei.
Also, wenn die Leute sich was beim Warten
angucken wollen,
was natürlich dann nicht so künstlerisch
wertvoll ist, ja, wie das von meinem Opa.
Ja, habe ich mitbekommen.
Ich weiß immer noch nicht.
Äh, denkst du, das tut was für Firefox
Marketshare? Kommt drauf an, wie
rigoros das Ganze umgesetzt wird.
Ich habe es mir in letzter Zeit nicht
angeguckt. Ich habe das immer mal wieder
mitbekommen.
Äh, gab es nicht.
Irgendwie. Muss doch mal bei Google
gucken. Max FPS
Suppe, genau. News.
Manifest V3 zeigt ab Juni
Werbe-Warn-Banner für Manifest V2.
Ach, come on.
Geh mir nicht auf den Sack, Alter.
Also, wenn das wirklich der Fall ist.
Sollte irgendwie hier
beispielsweise uBlock und so rausfliegen,
beziehungsweise stark
in der Funktion eingeschränkt werden,
dann wird mein Main-Browser wieder
Firefox werden. Ja, und was
fliegt raus? Man weiß es natürlich.
uBlock. Was weiß man denn dazu?
Mal gespannt.
Ich bin mal gespannt, ja. Aber sollte,
wie gesagt, sollte Werbe-Blocker nicht
möglich mehr sein, gescheit,
dann wird es einfach Firefox
geben, weil das Internet mit Werbung
kann ich mir nicht geben. Das ist
unmöglich.
Es nervt
mich ja schon, dass es so schwierig
geworden ist auf YouTube,
wobei auf YouTube geht es noch ein bisschen besser,
dass es so schwierig geworden ist auf Twitch
die Werbung loszuwerden.
Du kannst den Channel subscriben,
jup, das funnst.
Aber
Twitch schafft es regelmäßig,
dass Werbung durch den Werbe-Blocker durchkommt.
NoScript war früher
das Beste überhaupt.
Mittlerweile habe ich kein NoScript.
Zumindest nicht im Chrome.
Ich kann bei aktueller Werbung nicht mitreden.
Ich schau mir keine Werbung an.
Und wenn ich eine unskippable Werbung
habe, dann minimiere ich das
Fenster, bis die weg ist.
Ich konsumiere so wenig
wie möglich Werbung.
Ist jetzt Spaghetti-Bolognese-Zeit? Ja!
Jetzt ist gleich 13 Uhr.
Heute haben wir, heute war da der
Schwätz-Anteil etwas höher als
der Video-Guck-Anteil. Muss aber auch mal sein.
Ich weiß, dass es Möglichkeiten gibt,
aber aktuell komme ich mit dem normalen Ad-Block
gut genug durch. Es kommt nur ab und zu mal Werbung
durch, das ist okay.
Das ist gut, gut zu wissen.
Was?
Na klar geht das weiter.
Ich mach das regelmäßig.
Klar geht das weiter.
Also ich weiß nicht, ob das hier weitergeht.
Ja? Aber das hier geht
auf jeden Fall, wenn du einfach auf ein anderes Fenster switchst.
Doch, doch, das geht auf jeden Fall.
Wenn du auf ein anderes Fenster switchst, ist das weg.
Es läuft weiter.
Auf Mobile vielleicht.
Kann man auf dem Handy irgendwie ohne Werbung
YouTube schauen? Du meinst, ohne YouTube Premium
kaufen zu müssen?
Ja. Es gibt ein paar
Browser mit
Werbeblockern. Auch unter
iOS. Unter Android
ist es easy. Unter Android kannst du sowas
hier verwenden zum Beispiel. Aber auch
unter, aber auch unter iOS
geht das. Aber unter
Android hast du deutlich mehr Varianten
und Möglichkeiten.
Ich hab das Problem nicht mehr
mit YouTube. Ich hab ja seit
Jahren YouTube
Premium
über
Indien, über ein indisches Payment
Profil. Ich hab das
aufgesetzt über
einen
über eine VM
bei DigitalOcean.
Warum Indien?
Weil das schon günstig ist in Indien.
In Indien kostet das,
frag mich nicht, indische
Rupien und indische Rupien umgerechnet in Euro.
Du bezahlst irgendwie 3 Euro oder so für YouTube Premium.
Über, über
in indischer Währung.
Der einzige Nachteil ist
und das ist aber wirklich auch der einzige,
den ich feststellen konnte.
Bei, wenn man
sich angucken möchte bei YouTube Music
was im Trend
ist, wenn du dort auf YouTube Music
gehst und sagst
Charts Top 100 oder sowas.
Dann kriegst du irgendwelchen Bollywood Kram.
Aber das stört mich nicht.
Ich hör mir eh nie Charts und Top 100 an.
Und ansonsten
sind die Recommendations und meine normale Musik
tun ganz normal.
Ja, ich weiß nicht wieviel
es in Indien kostet. Immer billig, ja.
Was ist YouTube
Lite? Was gibt's da?
Das kenn ich gar nicht.
Ja, das kenn ich.
Das kenn ich.
Ich mag Twitch tatsächlich am liebsten
im Browser zu schauen.
Wegen Chat und allem. Ja, ich weiß es gibt auch externe Chat
Clients und man kann den Chat rauspoppen und so.
Aber ich finde
die Browser Experience
Twitch immer noch am besten.
Ach, Lite ist ohne Musik.
Ok. Nun gut.
Schauen wir mal ob es neue Package Updates gibt.
Weil wir sind ja unter 8.
Da kann ja durchaus mal alle 2 Minuten
neues Package Update kommen. Ne, kommt nicht.
Gut, Leute. Dann
geh ich jetzt Spaghetti
mit Tomatensauce futtern.
Mal kurz was schauen.
Zed ist jetzt im Arch Extra Repo.
Nochmal installieren. Haben wir das
nicht letztes Mal schon installiert?
Ach ne, wir haben über User
Repo installiert das letzte Mal.
Ok, Moment.
Wollte nochmal streamen. Ich weiß nicht.
Nicht entschieden.
Hier extra. Nice.
Ja, das wird wieder nicht
funktionieren, weil Valken
Valken mag in der
Z
Ach, groß.
Force Champ? Ne.
Kann man das Render Backend hier irgendwie ändern?
Der mag das nicht.
Ich glaub der hat Probleme mit Valken
auf der VM. Kann man dem
sagen OpenGL Render Backend
oder kann der nur Valken rendern?
Da muss ich wohl auf Blazingly Fast
Written in Rust
Editor erstmal verzichten.
Alles klar, Leute. Wir hören uns.
Ich geh jetzt was futtern. Bis denn.
See you.